Wir klaren. Genau, ansonsten würde ich am Anfang
sagen,
ich weiß nicht,
ob ihr mal eine Folge von dem hier gehört habt,
ich sage immer, hi Kilian, und Kilian sagt,
hi Henrik, wenn wir gestern haben, machen wir es im Kreis,
das heißt, ich sage, hi Kilian, und Kilian
sagt den Nächsten, und der Nächste sagt den Übernächsten,
und der Nächste sagt dann wieder, hi Henrik.
Okay, und dann ist es schwierig,
weil wir sind ja, oh Gott.
Ihr müsst jetzt im Kopf
euch merken, wer noch nicht dran war,
euch dann zufällig jemand anders aussuchen.
Es ist bei 4.0.
Es wird auch eine 50-50-Chance
hinauslaufen.
Gut, okay, dann machen wir es einfach mal zum Spaß.
Hi, Kilian!
Hi, Kilian! Oh, ich habe es verkackt.
Hey Finn. Hi Jörg. Hi Hendrik. Willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 51 und wir haben dieses Mal wunderbare Gäste zu besuchen, nämlich den Finn und den Jörg. Schön, dass ihr da seid.
Schön, dass wir da sein dürfen.
Wir hatten uns nämlich ein kleines Thema
schon länger mal zurechtgelegt.
In unserem wunderbaren
akronomisierbar
Fan-Channel, Matrix,
wurde dieses Thema vorgeschlagen.
Ich glaube von Jörg.
Jörg war auch schon mal in der Sendung.
Frag mich jetzt nicht nach der Folgennummer.
Wir wollen heute reden über
Rust im Linux-Körnel.
Das ist jetzt der Punkt,
wo ich quasi schon raus bin.
Bei Rust oder beim Linux-Körnel?
Bei Rust kann ich noch ein bisschen mitreden,
beim Linux-Körnel nur ganz marginal.
Aber wie kommt es denn, dass ihr euch damit auskennt?
Wer seid ihr eigentlich und was macht ihr?
Jörg.
Ja, also ich bin mit meinem PhD,
komme ich eigentlich immer wieder an die Grenzen des Linux-Körners.
Ich arbeite meistens, also drumherum,
ich habe zum Beispiel ein Projekt gemacht,
da ging es um Container.
Da habe ich so ein kleines Fuse-Dateisystem implementiert,
was man in den Container reinmorten kann.
Und damit konnte man so seine Tools in den Container bringen.
Da habe ich mich dann auch angefangen,
intensiv so mit Kernel-Internas zu beschäftigen,
so was Performance angeht und so weiter.
Dann hatte ich so ein anderes kleines Projekt.
Da ging es um SGX, was so eine Security-Technologie ist,
mit der man Code in so einer gesicherten Umgebung,
in so einer Sendbox ausführen kann.
Und ich habe da auch wieder I.O. schneller gemacht.
Ich habe da auch den Linux-Kernel selber ganz schön getunt
und so verschiedene Subsystemen gearbeitet,
das Speichersubsystem,
wo ich dann den Allokator
umgeschrieben habe und ja, da bin ich
schon ziemlich tief in den Kernel reingegangen, also
das sind selbst wahrscheinlich viele Kernelentwickler,
die da wahrscheinlich in diese Teile
reingucken und
ja, in meinem aktuellen Projekt
habe ich dann was gemacht, wo
ich dann noch mehr mit Rast und dem Liegingskernel
zu tun habe und zwar
geht es darum,
dass man, wenn man so eine virtuelle Maschine
hat, kriegt man ja erstmal
so keinen Zugriff, also man kann nicht von außen,
vom Hypervisor kann man jetzt nicht so einfach Prozesse
in der Form spawnen, also starten.
Außer man hat jetzt irgendwie zum Beispiel ein SSH da drin,
also man braucht irgendwie normalerweise irgendwie
in dem VM-Gast braucht man irgendwie eine Möglichkeit,
irgendwie einen Agent oder irgendwas.
Und mein Projekt geht halt darum, dass man da einfach Prozesse so injectet.
Also ich hänge mich dann in dem Projekt, was WMSH heißt,
an die Formen ran, vom Host aus.
Und spawn dann, oder inject the code in den Hypervisor,
der dann in der Erlegungsform ausgeführt wird
und dann dort ein Proc-Device mounted, also ein Dateisystem,
und eine kleine Shell.
Und die kann man das dann wieder nach außen hin verbunden.
Und das ist halt alles komplett in Rast geschrieben.
selbst der Teil, der dann
in den Kernel
ein-encheckt wird. Allerdings
benutze ich jetzt kein Modul, was ich
reinlade, sondern ich tue das wirklich von außen
vom Hypervisor
an die richtige Stelle kopieren und dann einfach
die vor allem dazu
bewegen, den Code auszuführen.
Du gehst jetzt schon
extrem tief ins Detail rein.
Vielen Dank erstmal, Jörg.
Die Frage war, wer seid ihr und was
macht ihr?
Vielleicht können wir da, also da sind ein paar, das klang super gut und ich habe auch aufgrund meines Studiums den Kontext gehabt, einen Teil davon zu verstehen, aber vielleicht sollten wir da nachher nochmal hinkommen. Ich würde die Frage gerne nochmal an Finn stellen. Was führt dich in unsere Runde?
Ja, prinzipiell habe ich gerade mein Abi gemacht und mache jetzt auch demnächst ein Studium in Informatik. Und ich arbeite seit irgendwie anderthalb Jahren bei einer Firma, die Zugsicherungssysteme macht. Und da haben wir halt auch Linux-Maschinen, die aber halt sehr spezifisch arbeiten.
und da hatten wir eine Zeit lang, dass wir
wirklich nach Ivy einen Shell
machen und das habe ich jetzt zum Beispiel auch ausgetauscht
durch einen direkten Netlink-Request,
sodass wir keinen neuen Prozess dafür
spawnen müssen und das ist so
eine der Dinge, die mich an den Linux-Körnel rangebracht hat,
weil ich dann halt dafür einmal den Linux-Körnel
durchgelesen habe, um das besser zu verstehen.
Einmal durchgelesen, den Linux-Körnel durchgelesen?
Das klingt so, wie ich habe die Beetle einmal von vorne
bis hinten durchgebracht.
Ich habe nur den Teil der Netlink-Macht
für das durchgelesen und dann bin ich halt irgendwie zu RAST
gekommen, weil RAST mache ich sowieso da in der Firma und
mache ich ganz gern. Und das
habe ich dann halt auch mal weitergemacht, habe ein bisschen
angeschaut, habe dann so ein
Projekt gefunden, was halt den
Linux-Körnel-Module in RAST
schreibt. Damals war es sogar noch out of tree.
Aber genau da, als ich dazu
kam, sind die gerade dazu gewechselt,
dass sie Intree machen und mehr oder minder
seitdem arbeite ich da mit und
bin halt dann dementsprechend an diesem
RAST-Vor-Linux-Projekt dabei.
Ah, cool, sehr schön.
Also, vielen Dank. Ich würde an dieser Stelle einfach mal versuchen, das, was ich jetzt gehört habe, für unsere Zuhörer in handliche, mundgerechte Fragen umzuformulieren.
Also, es gibt einen Linux-Körnel, den muss man vielleicht nicht unbedingt einführen, aber der ist der Kern des Betriebssystems.
Und nun ist die Frage, was hat denn Rust mit dem Linux-Körnel überhaupt zu tun und in welchem Verhältnis stehen diese beiden miteinander?
Nun habt ihr gerade gesagt, ihr erarbeitet
beide an Linux-Körnel-Modulen.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Handelt es sich immer um Module?
Ja, da gibt es nur einen Unterschied bei dem,
wo ich mache. Das sind normale Module,
wie man sie mit lsmod kennt.
Und bei Jörg, das sind etwas speziellere,
die man da auch gar nicht sieht.
Also so ein Modul ist im Linux-Körnel,
wenn ich es jetzt nochmal
versuche zusammenzufassen, quasi so eine Art Plugin.
Das ist wie so ein
so ein SO oder DLL
für Leute,
was zur Runtime geladen wird
und dann kann man Code im
Kernelspace ausführen, der nicht Teil
der Kernel-Binary ist
und die muss ein spezifisches
C-Interface erfüllen.
Im Genauen ist es ein K-O-Kernel-Objekt,
so wie ein SO ein Shared-Objekt ist.
So, und der Linux-Kernel ist ja selber
in C geschrieben.
Größtenteils. So, jetzt kann ich verstehen, dass man da
gerne auch mal neue Sachen in Rust machen
die Motivation müsst ihr mir, glaube ich,
gar nicht erklären, weil die ist relativ offensichtlich.
Jeder, der einmal Rust gemacht hat,
möchte ab jetzt nur noch alles in Rust machen.
Unabhängig von den Sicherheitsversprechen.
Und ihr habt euch jetzt hingesetzt und gesagt,
wir schreiben jetzt Kernelmodule in Rust?
Oder wie ging das los?
Was waren am Anfang die Schwierigkeiten?
Ging das einfach so?
Oder du hast gerade gesagt,
da gab es am Anfang so ein Projekt.
Könntest du da nochmal drauf eingehen finden?
Und ganz am Anfang habe ich, als ich dazu kam, also im Linux-Körnel gibt es halt auch Debug-Funktionalitäten, so wie der richtige Debugger ist ja nicht ein GDB, sondern einfach ein Print. Und das gibt es halt auch im Linux-Körnel und da war irgendwas, was ich gesehen hatte, was ich dann versucht habe zu fixen.
Und so kam ich da an, dass ich dann halt einfach in dem Loader-Konstrukt drumherum, also in der Library, die man damals noch hatte, dass mir da was in der Print-Funktion nicht gefiel und das habe ich dann gefixt.
So bist du zu Rast-Volimus
gekommen. Ja.
Was hat der
Loader mit Rast zu tun an der Stelle?
Ne, beziehungsweise der
Loader, beziehungsweise die Library, die halt
damals noch für das Out-of-Tree-Modul war,
um das einfacher zu machen,
dass man nicht das immer komplett neu erfinden muss,
sondern dass man bestimmte Interfaces,
beziehungsweise Trade heißt es ja, in Rast, implementieren
muss und dann bauen kann
und dass dann da direkt ein
Kernel-Objekt rausfällt, was halt schon die ganzen
Interfaces einfacher implementiert, als man das
jedes Mal von Hand neu machen muss.
Achso, weil die Interfaces, die man implementieren muss, sind
ein C-Interface quasi, damit
man nach außen wie eine C-Library aussieht
und das ist was diese Library,
wie heißt die?
Damals hieß das noch
Linux-Kernel-Module-Wast, das ist das erste Projekt.
Irgendwann auch Kernel-Objekt. Genau, und da muss man
quasi sich nur gegen implementieren und dann
kriegt man das C-Interface quasi frei Haus.
Ja, man muss bestimmte
Strings in
haben, ja.
Also du hast im Prinzip
in der Shared Library, da hast du dann
eine Art
Einstiegspunkte, die der Kernel sucht.
Da stehen auch sowas drin wie, okay,
das Modul ist jetzt unter der GPL
oder
das Modul
exportiert jetzt folgende Funktionen
oder, ja, und wenn man
halt irgendwie Funktionen braucht, dann linkt man gegen die
und der Kernel versucht dann beim Laden
des Moduls diese Funktion zu finden
und wenn es die nicht gibt, dann
kann man das Kernel-Modul nicht laden.
Der Kernel guckt zur Runtime,
ob die Lizenz GPL ist?
Ja, also wenn man ein Kernel-Modul lädt,
was keine GPL ist, dann wird der Kernel
als Tainted markiert.
Und da steht dann auch überall drin, wenn man
Fehlermeldungen hat, also wenn
ein Kernel-Ups passiert, dann steht dann drin, oh, der Kernel
ist Tainted und dann ist man ein klein schlechterer
Mensch auf jeden Fall.
Und es gibt aber auch...
Das ist ja großartig.
Es gibt auch so Nose, die nur für GPL exportiert werden, sprich, wenn man halt nicht GPL-Modul ist, dann kann man nicht auf alle Funktionen vom Kernel zugreifen.
Genau, ich bin zum Beispiel, ich mag zum Beispiel ZFS und das ist, da gibt es ja das Problem, dass ZFS, der Treiber, also dieses Dateisystem, das ist nie unter der GPL, weil bewusst von den Gründern von einem ZFS-Projekt wurde eine Lizenz gewählt, die inkompatibel zum GPL ist.
Das hindert aber nie daran, Leute trotzdem ZFS und Linux weiter und weiter zu pushen.
Und das ist eigentlich jetzt gerade so der neue Upstream.
Also die gesamte Entwicklung ist quasi in das ZFS und Linux-Projekt übergegangen.
Aber man hat halt dann nach wie vor immer Probleme,
dass irgendwie Körnelsymbole gerne mal verschwinden können mit einem neuen Update
oder dann irgendwie zu GPL auch immer gemacht werden.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich bei mir zu Hause,
wenn ich meinen Artstellungs-Update immer explizit
den Kernel nicht mit-update, sondern
warte, bis irgendwie das ZFS und Linux
auch mit der Kernel-Version, mit der nächsten kompatibel ist.
Sonst kann ich manchmal meine Festplatten nicht machen.
Sorry, Finn.
Für ZFS gibt es dann auch dieses
GPL-Kondom in der Regel, was dann irgendwie
GPL-Symbole
ein bisschen verändert, sodass die Logik nicht mehr
ganz so ist und sie dann exportiert als nicht GPL.
Gott, was ein Begriff.
Ich hatte auch mal irgendwas im Patch
gemacht für das nächste Projekt.
für ZFS, wo ich dann noch bei
VogueRenix zu lesen war. Und zwar hatten die
irgendwann
in Linux was kaputt gemacht,
um
wenn du einen Linux-Körnel hast, dann
kannst du nicht die ganze Zeit so Fließkommazahlen
Berechnungen machen, weil die werden in der Regel ausgeschaltet
aus Performance-Gründen.
Und diese Funktionen, die sind dann einfach
verschwunden und dadurch konnte dann
ZFS eine Zeit lang nie diese
erweiterten Krypto-Funktionen
von der CPU
benutzen, um zum Beispiel
IIS-Verschlüsselung oder
Checksum-Berechnung schneller zu machen.
Und da hatte ich dann
einfach diesen Patch revertet und
in NixOS auf allen Kerneln applied.
Und dann kam dann auch so ein Poronix-Artikel
dabei rum, der dann gesagt hat,
hier, NixOS ist jetzt die schnellste
hat jetzt die schnellste
ZFS-Implitierung.
Aber das haben wir dann irgendwann in ZFS wieder selber
gefixt.
Also im Kernel-Modus kann man keine
Fließkommazahlen-Berechnung machen?
Ja, also der Hintergrund ist, wenn man in den Kernel reinspringt,
soll das ja möglichst schnell passieren.
Und was du machen musst, ist, wenn du irgendwie in den Kontext switchst,
dann musst du die Register alle irgendwie weg sichern.
Also die CPU-Register, das sind quasi so das CPU-State,
wo zum Beispiel steht, okay, ich bin jetzt gerade an der Stelle im Programm,
also das sind so Instruction-Pointer zum Beispiel,
und diesen State muss man weg sichern.
Wenn jetzt Floating-Point aktivierst,
dann musst du genau diese Fließkommaregister auch mit wegsichern.
Und das ist halt zusätzlicher Overhead.
Und das sind halt viele Daten.
Und deswegen wird das im Kernel in der Regel deaktiviert,
weil du brauchst eigentlich im Kernel sehr selten Flirting-Point-Operationen.
Ach so, das heißt, wenn man das anmacht,
dann hat man zwar schnellere ZFS, aber einen langsameren Kernel.
Ja, also in ZFS wird das dann auch bloß in bestimmten Kontexten eingeschaltet.
Da gibt es dann irgendwie Fretz, die machen jetzt zum Beispiel Verschlüsselung
und die machen das dann an.
Aber viele andere Teile, die brauchen dann keine Flirting-Point-Sachen.
Operation. Und auch sowas wie U128,
der Rasttyp, der ist auch in der Regel
im Kernel deaktiviert und funktioniert nicht.
Also U128-Bit-Integer.
Ja.
Weil man für die auch Sonderhandstände
machen muss, wenn man keine
128-Bit-Architektur hat quasi.
Ich weiß jetzt gerade nur, wie es im Rastteil ist.
Ich meine, da ist es so, weil das andere
Compiler-Bit-Ins braucht.
Ob es im Rest des C-Quotes
ist, weiß ich gerade gar nicht. Ich habe hauptsächlich
bis jetzt im Körner gemacht.
Das ist auch ein super Detail.
Nochmal kurze
Anmerkung aus der Regie. Wir fallen uns
manchmal ein bisschen ins Wort. Also wenn ihr was sagen wollt, mal kurz
die Hand heben, dann können die anderen auch Rücksicht auf mich nehmen.
Super, cool.
Also wir waren jetzt gerade an
welchem Punkt?
Welche Frage würde ich jetzt erst stellen?
Ja, das ist alles...
Sorry, go ahead.
Nee, sag.
Ich meine, das ist
alles so viel mehr Low-Level als
was ich mich so jeden Tag auseinandersetze.
Ich würde es absolut faszinieren.
Ja, aber das klingt doch jetzt so,
als müsste man quasi nur diese Library nehmen,
Linux-Kernel-Modul-Rust,
und sein Projekt
damit bauen oder dagegen
bauen und dann kann man
ein Rust-Kernel-Modul bauen. Was ist denn
daran jetzt so schwierig? Warum machen wir da einen ganzen Podcast drüber?
Das ist halt
mittlerweile anders, weil dieses
Linux-Kernel-Modul Rust ist halt genau gerade
defricated worden, als ich dazu kam.
Und wir sind halt zu einem Intry-Modul
rüber gewechselt, sprich wir haben jetzt, wenn das
dann irgendwann mal gemerged wird von
Dinos Torvils, haben wir in dem
Dinosource-Code
direkt den Ordner Rust und da liegen die ganzen
Abstractions drin
und dann kann man sogar direkt einfach
ich kann dann die Datei
drivers.net.dummy.rs.res anlegen
und muss das nur dem
Mac-File geben, dass du dieses Objekt auch bauen sollst
dem Kernel-Mac-File,
cabled heißt das Ganze und dann wird es
gebaut sogar mittlerweile.
Und das ist diese gleiche Library, bloß im Körnel?
Ja, sie ist seitdem deutlich gewachsen.
Das war irgendwie 4. Oktober 2020, als das gerade sich gewechselt hat.
Seitdem ist einige Zeit vergangen, da ist ganz schön viel dazugekommen.
Krass, das heißt, ich baue jetzt meinen Rust-Code zusammen mit dem Linux-Körnel?
Ja.
Ah ja.
Wenn das aktiviert wird in der Config vom Linux-Körnel.
Das heißt, wir unterscheiden jetzt zwischen Rust-Code, der als Kernel-Modul gebaut wird,
und Rust-Code, der direkt als Teil vom Kernel gebaut wird?
Die meisten Module kann man auch direkt in, Bild-In machen.
Sprich, zum Beispiel dieses Dummy-S-Modul, das habe ich halt geschrieben.
Es gibt diesen Netzwerk-Dummy, der war früher in C.
Da gibt es auch noch den C und ich habe halt gerade noch ein PR offen,
dass der auch in Rust geschrieben ist, eine zweite Implantation, um zu zeigen, wie das gehen würde.
den kann ich auch zum Beispiel Build-In machen, dann ist das gar kein Modul,
sondern ist das direkt in jedem Kernel, der damit gebaut worden ist, drin.
Und wenn ich das halt nicht als Build-In mache, dann ist es ein Modul, was ich nachstrecklich laden kann.
Ach, das ist, wenn ich jetzt meinen Kernel selber baue, was ich so als Optionales anfangen mit anchecken würde.
Ja, also warum will man sowas im Kernel 3 mit drin haben?
Also der Kernel entwickelt sich halt ziemlich schnell weiter.
Und innerhalb, also die Kernel-Abliste sind halt alles andere als stabil.
Also wenn man ein externes Projekt hat, dann hängt man da immer hinterher eigentlich.
Also du musst dann eigentlich, du musst da eigentlich, das ist eine Vollzeitaufgabe,
wenn du ein Out-of-Tree-Kernel-Modul entwickelst.
Deswegen will man das schon mit im Tree drin haben.
Zumal es dadurch auch hier bessere Bildsystem-Integrationen gibt,
dass man halt wirklich das mit den Make-Files, die der Kernel benutzt, auch vermitteln kann.
Also zu dem K-Bild kann ich vielleicht nochmal was sagen.
Also gute Makefile-Systeme zu schreiben,
ist schon ziemlich schwierig.
Ein Carbilt ist eigentlich, würde ich sagen,
einer der besseren Systeme, die ich da jetzt gesehen habe.
Also das ist auch ganz gut,
wenn man mal irgendwie so Benchmarks machen will,
so ein Linux-Kernel-Compile,
da kriegt man schon alle Cores ordentlich ausgelastet.
Und die Abstraktion ist auch ziemlich elegant, würde ich sagen.
Also ja, wieder diese Config-Optionen, die man da definiert,
die da irgendwie Features einschalten, wie das integriert ist,
das ist schon ziemlich nett gemacht.
Und ich glaube, Finn hat auch irgendwie am Anfang
an diesem Cargobel-System da Sachen mit integriert,
um den Rast-Compiler, der zum Kompilieren von Rast verwendet wird,
dass quasi der verwendet wird,
anstatt dass man irgendwie durch das Cargobel-System geht,
was ein normaler Weg ist, wie man Rast baut.
Das heißt, ihr habt jetzt direkt selber mit am Linux-Körnel
und an der Integration von Rust im Linux-Körnel mitgearbeitet?
Ja, mehr oder minder.
Da muss ich leider sagen, das habe ich nicht gemacht, was Jörg gerade meinte.
Die Cargo-Tauschen durch die Rechte des Rust-Zieh, das hat Miguel gemacht.
Das ist mehr oder minder die Person, die das hauptsächlich macht.
Was ich gebastelt habe zum Beispiel,
man kann den Kernel mit O gleich irgendein Verzeichnis bauen,
damit der Output nicht in dem Input-Verzeichnis liegt,
um das ein bisschen auseinanderzubauen.
Das war anfangs, als ich dazu kam, kaputt.
Weil da an das Rast-C so viele Argumente übergeben worden sind,
dass wenn da jetzt auch noch ein Ordner zu kam,
dass dann die Maximal-Argumentlänge zu groß war.
Und da kann man aber glücklicherweise mit so einem Ad und einer Datei
dem Rast-C sagen, dass er mal die ganzen Argumente aus dieser Datei lesen soll
und dann geht das viel besser.
Und das heißt, der
Linux-Conner, wenn er gebaut wird,
der hat wahrscheinlich dann irgendwie eine bestimmte
Rust-C-Compiler-Version gepinnt
und benutzt die.
Aktuell ist es gepinnt.
Und benutzt er dann noch Cargo oder wird direkt
Rust-C aufgerufen?
Es wird direkt Rust-C rausgerufen.
Es war anfangs nicht Cargo, es ist komplett rausgeflogen.
Weil es halt auch
deutlich einfacher ist. Es ist zwar ein mehr oder minder
Unstable Interface.
Vor allen Dingen, da wir einen Beta-Rust-C
nutzen aktuell. Wir nutzen den
1.45er.
Aber es ist komplett RAS-C und wir haben
auch eine Clippy-Integration.
Dann auch über Clippy direkt und nicht über
irgendwie Cargo. Und wir haben auch RAS-Docs.
Machen wir auch.
Nicht schlecht. Aber ich schätze mal jemand,
der ein
Linux-Kernel-Modul,
ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal Modul weiterhin,
baut, der wird auch nicht viele
externe Dependencies da mit reinlegen.
Sowas wie Serde oder
was man
so benutzen könnte.
Gibt es irgendwelche Mechanismen oder
ist es einfach nicht möglich, externe Lips zu
verwenden? Aktuell ist es einfach nicht
möglich, externe Lips zu verwenden. Man kann die natürlich
selber vendoren und dann kann man das hinbekommen.
Dann liegen sie aber
quasi mit im Linux
Tree mit drin. Genau,
das ist halt gerne mal problematisch wegen
den Lizenzen.
Es ist auch noch, wir haben da ein eigenes
Makro-Crate mit
drin, so ein Pog-Makro und
dafür wollen wir auch irgendwann mal SYN nutzen,
das ist auch so eine Dependency von Serde.
Das haben wir aber auch noch nicht sinnvoll
hingekriegt. Zum einen wegen Lizenzen, glaube ich,
und auch zum anderen, weil es halt irgendwie kompliziert ist.
Ja, genau. Die meisten
Crates sind ja irgendwie unter
Apache-slash-MIT-Lizenz
oder sowas.
Welche war das?
Lizenzen sind meistens...
Da sind die in der Regel, ja.
Genau. Und ist das
Apache-MIT, genau. Ist das
kompatibel?
Soweit ich weiß nicht.
KPL, doch.
Also du kannst das relizenzieren
unter, also MIT müsste dir das erlauben,
dass du
das gegen GPL-Code linkst.
Das ist dann halt auch unter GPL dann.
Das adoptiert halt die andere Lizenz.
Aber ich glaube, die...
Es ist wahrscheinlich einfacher, irgendwas von MIT
nach GPL zu relicensen
als andersrum.
Restriktiver ist glaube ich
leichter in dem Sinn.
Was mir auch oft gefallen ist,
beziehungsweise wenn man so System Programming macht,
dass viele Quellen im Internet auch mittlerweile,
also wenn es irgendwie Dokumentation gibt,
ist es häufig irgendwie Leute, die aus der Rast-Community sind,
die da Dokumentation schreiben.
Und das merkt man ja auch im Lieblingskörnel.
Also wenn man im Lieblingskörnel so jetzt auch diese neuen Abstraktionen liest,
die jetzt der Rastkörnel oder dieses Rast-Subsystem im Körnel hinzufügt,
dann hat man auch immer so Dockstrings und so weiter.
Das kannte man vorher irgendwie,
es war sehr selten und sehr wenig dokumentiert
und die Rastleute, die haben
auf jeden Fall, die bringen da so eine neue Kultur rein,
muss ich sagen, wo es
nie bloß darum geht, dass man, okay, wenn ich jetzt
irgendwas verstehen will im News-Köbel, dann muss ich halt lesen,
wie es implementiert ist, sondern dass man irgendwie schon anhand
der Doku erkennt, was es macht.
Das klingt arg wertvoll.
Es gibt da sogar ein Hard-Requirement
drauf, also wir haben aktuell, das Projekt
läuft auf GitHub und kann aber auch
über Mailing-Liste entwickelt werden, also man kann
an die Rast-for-Linux-Mailing-Liste Dinge schicken
und die werden dann auch in GitHub
irgendwann gemerged dann als Git-Commit.
Genau.
Und es gibt halt ein Hardware-Requirement,
was von der CI entforced wird, dass es Dokumentationen gibt.
Und auch, es gibt hier
ein Rast, dieses Unsafe-Wort, um
auf Low-Level-Dinge hinzuzugreifen, wo der
Rast-Compiler dann nicht mehr sicher sein kann,
dass das safe ist.
All über diesen Zeilen muss man
ein Safety-Kommentar hinzufügen, sonst
gibt das Ärger.
Ah ja, das ist hier als Clippy-Warning-Deny
Uncommented Code und Deny
Unsave Code oder sowas, das ist wahrscheinlich dann einfach markiert.
Das geht ja auch so sinnvoll, das will man
ja auch an der Stelle haben.
Ich finde es lustig, dass die Kulturen,
also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wenn man
die Community so ein bisschen kennt,
so die Linux-Kernel-Community,
ich will jetzt nichts unterstellen, aber hat immer
den Anschein, dass es schon
eher hostile ist und
wenn du nicht perfekt einen Code schreibst,
dann wird dir der Arsch
aufgerissen, dass du keinen Bock mehr hast, in deinem Leben noch
jemals eine Keyboard anzufassen.
Und du vielleicht anfängst, deine Karriere-Choices zu überlegen, überdenken.
Und die Rust-Community gibt es auch manchmal schlechte Tage,
aber versucht eigentlich sehr freundlich und kommunikativ zu sein.
Habt ihr gemerkt, wie das aufeinander trifft?
Auf jeden Fall. Ich bin ja auf jeden Fall in der Mailing-Liste.
Ich bin zwar auch auf der Linux-Kernel-Mailing-Liste,
da lese ich aber nicht so viel, weil das einfach sehr viel Traffic ist.
Aber auf der Mailing-Liste schon allein, wo einfach nur Rust vor Linux ist
und wo dann halt gerade, wenn die die Merge-Windows sind
und Miguel wieder einen Patch Richtung Linus geschickt hat,
dann kommt da schon viel zurück.
Und hier, das ist ja unschön.
Und hier, das ist ja noch gar kein richtiger Treiber.
Und hier, das ist zwar ein Beindadtreiber,
den gibt es schon in Rast,
aber der fehlt noch so ein kleines Ding wie Dateisystem.
Da ist eine große Front.
Also das ist ein ganz anderer Ton, der da herrscht, meinst du?
Und Miguel ist jetzt einer von den Linus-Leuten?
Miguel ist einer der Linux-Leute, hat, soweit ich weiß, schon diverse Commits auch so im Upstream-Linus drin und das ist mehr oder minder der Hauptmann von dem Rast4Linus-Projekt.
Und soweit ich weiß, ist er mittlerweile auch irgendwie über Google irgendwo bezahlt, aber nicht direkt. Das bin ich aber auch nicht ganz sicher.
Ah, krass.
Ja, also Google hat auch irgendwie da so einen Fuß drin in dieser ganzen Rast-Entwicklung.
Die sind auch sehr interessiert, zum Beispiel den Kernel mit Clang zu kompilieren,
was eigentlich auch so eine Vorbedingung war, damit dieses Rastverlängerungsprojekt überhaupt möglich ist,
weil bevor der Kernel nie mit Clang kompilierbar war,
konnte man halt nie wirklich Rast-Bindings dafür bauen,
weil dieses Ganze, wie Bindings generiert werden, das basiert alles auf LVM und Clang-Parser,
deswegen hat es halt vorhin nie funktioniert.
Und Google hat halt auch ein starkes Interesse daran,
den Linkskernel mit Klang zu bauen.
Das machen die auf ihrer Android-Plattform.
Das hat dann halt auch die Konsequenz gehabt,
dass dann so viele Security-Hardenings, die so in so einem Klang drin sind,
dass die mittlerweile auch von Linkskernel benutzt werden.
Wetson ist einer der Leute, die dabei sind.
Der kommt von Google, der macht das Binder-Interface hauptsächlich
und schreibt das halt damit dann, dass Binder,
Das ist ja dieses Security-IPC-System unter Android, damit das dann in Rast läuft.
Und Nick ist auch dabei.
Nick macht nicht so viel an dem Rastkörner, aber der macht hauptsächlich das Projekt.
Das heißt, das Projekt heißt, dass man Klang mit Linux bauen kann.
Dabei ist aber interessant, dass man den Linuxkörner mit Rastsupport unter x86 sogar mit GCC bauen kann.
Und dann braucht man nur das Klang für den Rastpart.
Krass
Also wir haben, Moment
Linux wird mit GCC gebaut
das ist ja die GNU Compiler
Collection und
Clang ist der LLVM basierte
C, C++
Objective-C Compiler
und
Rust selber basiert
auf LLVM
zumindest hat als
Backend LLVM
jetzt habt ihr gerade angesprochen
dass Google daran interessiert ist
den Kernel
mit Clang zu bauen, was ist denn daran
kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man das braucht, weil
Rust ist nach unten
auch ein LLVM
sieht nach unten aus wie ein Clang
aber was ist denn jetzt die Schwierigkeit
von jeweils diesem Thema
also man könnte sich jetzt vorstellen
ich baue den Kernel mit Clang
oder ich baue Rust mit einem GCC
Backend, könnt ihr da ein bisschen was zu erzählen?
Ja, kann ich ein bisschen was zu erzählen.
Klang und GCC
hat teilweise verschiedene Kommandozahlen-Argumente
und auch andere Features, beziehungsweise
in Klang ist, glaube ich, ein anderes LTO-Modell
und das ist, meine ich, auch älter als in GCC.
LTO ist Link-Time-Optimization.
Genau,
und
da ist halt der Unterschied.
RAST baut zwar selber mit LLVM
direkt und gar keinen Klang dazwischen.
LLVM ist ja auch das Backend von Klang auch nur.
Aber Bindgen, das was wir nutzen,
um aus den Linux-Headern
Rast-Bindings
zu bauen, dass wir dann darüber Abstractions
bauen können, das nimmt die
Kommandozahlen-Argumente, die man an Klang gibt,
muss also entsprechend auf Klang gefiltert
sein und nicht auf GCC,
um daraus diese ganzen Abstractions, also eine
große Rast-Datei, mit zu machen.
Und da war er kurz weg.
Komplett weg.
Dann ziehe ich mal kurz weiter.
und zwar
ja man kann ja mit Rast
kann man ja gegen C prinzipiell linken
allerdings wenn man mal so eine Weile
im Linux-Körner liest, dann sieht man
dass dort viele
Makros auch verwendet werden
beziehungsweise also viele Sachen
die aussehen wie Funktionen, wenn man dann mal
gucken wo die nachher kommen, sind ja auch immer Makros
und es wird sehr viel verwendet, weil
du hast halt viel so performance-kritischen Code
und dann haben da irgendwie die Körnerentwickler
haben dann halt Inline-Funktionen
und sowas definiert
Und um die dann nutzen zu können, da braucht man dann auch zusätzlich noch Abstraktionen.
Also die Schwierigkeit ist, dass der Linux-Körnel nicht in C, sondern in GCCC geschrieben ist.
Das kommt noch dazu. Also Betriebssysteme sind eigentlich immer so ein guter Benchmark, wie tief so eine Systemsprache überhaupt geht.
Also es gibt viele Sachen, die man selbst auf C
draußen nie machen kann,
weil
so ein Betriebssystem braucht
halt irgendwie so Zugriff auf
CPU-Funktionalität,
die man ja einfach so nie bekommt.
Deswegen,
ja, also der GCC ist hochhistorisch,
war auch immer
offen dafür, dass Sachen, die der Linus-Kolle
braucht, mit in den GCC zu integrieren.
Deswegen hat das eine ganze Weile
gedauert, also von 2012
oder so, wo das
Leute angefangen haben,
Klängen kompatibel mit dem Linux-Kanal
oder umgedreht zu machen.
Ja, das habe ich schon vor einer Weile gelesen, dass das
als Projekt angefangen wurde.
2012 hast du gesagt?
Ja, also ich habe dann so rausgeguckt,
also genau kann ich es auch nicht
rekonstruieren, aber ich habe so ein Change-Log gesehen,
so 2012 haben dann so Leute angefangen,
so Talks darüber zu halten, wie man
Linux mit Klängen bauen kann
und dann hat es dann eine ganze Weile
gab es dann dieses LFM-Linux-Projekt
oder so hieß das.
Die haben halt dann so Patches gehabt, damit das funktioniert.
Und irgendwann hat dann Clang, ich glaube, das war ein Clang 9,
der hat dann alle Funktionalität gehabt,
sodass man den Kernel ohne Patches bauen kann.
Da gab es dann so einen Phonics-Artikel.
Und ja, mittlerweile braucht man irgendwie Clang 11 oder so.
Und dann kann man dann den Linux mitbauen.
Das habe ich gestern erst gemacht.
Also den muss man dann in einen bestimmten GCC-Modus schalten?
Oder?
Ja, also Clang versucht ja eigentlich die ganzen
Flex zu akzeptieren,
die der GCC so benutzt.
Das hat ja auch historische Gründe, weil zum Beispiel
auf Mac OS wird irgendwann mal GCC durch Clang ersetzt
und da hat Apple dann einige Sachen
eingebaut.
Beziehungsweise es gibt halt
also das Bildsystem vom
Linux-Kernel erkennt auch, wenn man den Clang
benutzt und fällt sich dann anders.
Ist dann einfach kompatibel.
Ah, cool. Wollen wir
irgendwie versuchen auf Fint zu warten?
Oder...
Edit Market 2.
Okay, cool.
Ich hoffe, das kommt nicht nochmal vor.
Wenn, dann sind wir mehr in Übung.
Genau.
Also gerade mal ganz kurz nicht da warst,
haben wir über, wie baut man Linux mit Clang gebaut
und was da die Schwierigkeiten von sind.
Man kann also jetzt den Linux-Körner mit Clang bauen seit Neuestem,
aber man kann auch Rust mit GCC bauen.
Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Nein.
Das geht leider noch nicht.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, ich meine, das war die Open Software Foundation, wenn die so heißt.
Die sponsert da gerade das Projekt GCC RS.
Und bei dem Projekt ist halt irgendwann, wenn das dann mal soweit ist, dass man dann Rast mit GCC bauen kann.
Es ist nur ein Frontend für GCC, sprich es ist dasselbe Backend, aber das kann, glaube ich, gerade mal irgendwie funktionieren ohne Trades, ohne alles.
Das wurde ja irgendwie ein bisschen kontrovers diskutiert.
warum man das jetzt überhaupt machen muss.
Also für Kontext, es gibt
den Ansatz, den Rust-Compiler
quasi nochmal
neu zu bauen und dann als
Backend GCC
zu verwenden anstatt LLVM.
Aber was quasi daran
kontrovers ist, ist die Tatsache, dass sie
das gesamte Frontend neu bauen.
Obwohl man das nicht unbedingt muss.
Es gibt dementsprechend jetzt glaube ich drei
aktuell einigermaßen maintainte
Rust-Compiler. Den original
C, den MRUST C, der so ein
GCC, nee,
ein C++ basierter RUST Compiler ist
und hauptsächlich dazu da ist,
den eigentlichen RUST Compiler zu bootstrappen.
Ist der MRUST C nicht dafür
da, um aus RUST Code C Code zu machen,
den man dann mit LLVM oder auch
GCC zu bauen? Genau,
der kompiliert RUST zu C,
damit man das dann zum Beispiel mit GCC
bauen könnte.
Na, den MRUST C,
der wird, wie gesagt, gerne zum
Strappen von Rust benutzt.
Ich glaube, das sind die Leute
aus der Geeks-Community.
Also die versuchen da irgendwie alles
reproduzierbar zu bauen.
Also die sind echt Hardcore-Drag.
Und das hat dann beim MRust-See zum Beispiel zur Folge,
dass man, oder bei Rust generell,
wenn man einen Rust-Compiler compilt,
dann muss man eigentlich nur die Rust-Version von davor nehmen.
Also eine Version ist nochmal wie minus eins.
Und der MRust-See
ist aber halt komplett unabhängig davon.
Der kann aber dann allerdings nicht jede Rast-Version
bauen. Der kann halt ein bisschen ältere bauen und
dann irgendwann upgradet mal wieder jemand was
und fixt wieder was in M-Rast-C
und dann kann man wieder eine neue Version bauen.
Das hat aber zur Folge...
Ja, da hast du dann irgendwie so 20
Versionen von Rast-C, die du dann nacheinander
baust und die sind echt hardcore
und die bauen das dann echt durch. Also es gibt Leute, die haben
zum Beispiel versucht, ein Mixworks-Projekt einzubauen
und da habe ich dann aber gesagt, als Rast-Maintener,
naja, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen unpraktikabel,
so viele Rast-Versionen zu bauen. Also zu viel
Rechenzeit hat niemand.
Ja, am Eisbären.
Genau, und deswegen möchte man jetzt quasi alles nochmal von vorne machen.
Es sind ja beides quasi aber trotzdem zwei Extreme.
Das eine baut den gesamten Compiler von vorne neu
und baut es aber bloß bis C,
um das dann von da mit einem beliebigen C-Compiler neu zu bauen.
Das andere baut das gesamte Frontend neu,
um es nur mit GCC bauen zu können.
Kann man nicht einfach den Rust-Compiler, wie er ist, nehmen und sagen,
ich mache jetzt das aktuell existierende
Haupt-Maintain-The-Frontend
kompatibel mit einem anderen Backend,
oder ist das nicht möglich?
Ja, also
man kann das schon machen, aber dann beschränkt
man sich halt auf die Plattformen, die LFM
supportet und GCC läuft halt
quasi überall, also wenn es
kein GCC-Bankend ist, dann ist die Plattform
quasi nie vorhanden.
Ich meine, dass man
sagt, ich
nehme den Rust-C-Compiler, wie er gerade
existiert und modifiziere den so, dass er
sowohl LLVM als auch GCC als
Backend nutzen kann.
Soweit ich das
Ganze sehe, ist halt, dass das LLVM,
das heißt das Lipklang
oder so, das ist so eine Dynamik Library, die kann man
halt einfach inkludieren und so macht
das halt der Rast C, soweit ich weiß.
Und auch Beingen dependet einfach auf Lipklang.
Und
GCC ist aber, soweit ich das bis jetzt
verstanden habe, ich habe da nur kurz reingeschaut,
das will ich mal nach dem Studium, wenn ich ein bisschen mehr von Ahnung
von Compiler habe, mir genauer anschauen,
ist dieses Ganze halt,
dass man da wirklich ein Frontend bauen muss und
das nicht ein Dynamik-Objekt
ist, gegen das man denkt für GCC,
sondern man ist wirklich im GCC selber drin.
Sprich, man muss es auch in C schreiben,
damit es sinnvoll funktioniert oder halt
direkt ein Aesthetic
GCC-Binding
zu RAS, das würde auch funktionieren, aber
sie haben sich für direktes C entschieden.
So, also das heißt,
es gibt jetzt diesen GCC-RS-Compiler?
Noch gibt's den nicht wirklich.
Noch gibt's den nicht wirklich, aber der soll dann quasi
derjenige sein, mit dem die ganzen Rust-basierten
C-Körnel-Module,
die Linux-Körnel-Module gebaut werden.
Wenn, das ist
irgendwann mal die Hoffnung, genau, aber aktuell ist es halt,
dass es einfach mit Rust-C gebaut wird.
Achso, also das heißt,
momentan geht's schon irgendwie, aber ich muss
einen Linux-Körnel mit Clang bauen,
damit ich da meine Rust-Module
ranlenken kann.
Wie ich das am Anfang schon mal gesagt habe, das ist nicht auf allen Systemen so.
Also zum Beispiel auf x86 habe ich das schon getestet.
Es ist zwar kein Requirement, kann also jederzeit brechen.
Aber ich habe auf x86 den Linux-Körnel mal gebaut.
Und da habe ich dann mit GTC den C-Teil gebaut.
Und dann mit einem normalen Rastzie den anderen Teil.
Und das hat auch funktioniert und hat auch gebootet.
Ah, cool.
Aber das war dann nicht gelinkt, sondern das war dann dynamisch geladen.
Nö, das hatte auch, also die Teile davon hat er auch gelinkt.
Den Rast-Core-Teil, also das, was in dem Source-Tree-Rast liegt,
das ist mitgelingt
richtig in Kernel.
Ah, okay, krass. Also es geht
irgendwie. Es könnte noch besser gehen, aber es geht bereits
irgendwie. Es kann halt jederzeit
irgendwie brechen und das ist dann halt natürlich auch irgendwie
unschön. Deswegen gibt es da kein, es gibt
kein, ja, das funktioniert, sondern probier
es aus, maybe funktioniert es.
Hat der Linux-Kernel eigentlich, wie ist der
Entwicklungsprozess von Linux-Kernel? Haben die CI?
Kann man da irgendwie sagen?
Mein Rust-Modul
funktioniert heute und morgen kriege ich
eine E-Mail, weil es nicht mehr funktioniert? Oder muss man das
selber machen. Zwei grinsenden Teilnehmer
hier sollten darauf, dass es
wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach ist.
Für das Rast
ist es sogar halbwegs einfach, für alles andere
ist es nicht so einfach. Es gibt da
den Google Sky, SkyDars
glaube ich heißt es, ich weiß gerade nicht mehr genau, wie er geschrieben
wird. Das ist ein
Cisco-Crawler,
Fusia, glaube ich,
und so weiter fort. Der nimmt dann halt,
also normalerweise wird der Linux-Kernel auf der
Mailing-Liste entwickelt. Linux-Kernel
at vg.kernel.org
Mail-Adresse, all sowas.
Und da geht dann halt, ein Intel-Bot gibt's
oder zwei, ein Google-Oder-Zwei-Bot gibt's,
die nehmen sich die Patches,
applyen die auf einen aktuellen Linux-Tree,
schauen, ob das überhaupt applyt, wenn nicht,
dann schreiben sie schon zurück, ja, nee, nee, das funktioniert
so nicht. Wenn es applyt, dann testen sie es,
teilweise mit einer Wend-Config, teilweise mit
irgendwelchen Dev-Config, was auch immer,
und dann gibt's einfach auf den
Thread eine Antwort,
funktioniert, funktioniert nicht.
Da hab ich auch
eine Geschichte aus
meinem persönlichen Umfeld, und zwar
wir haben
für unser Projekt wollten wir
dann so ein experimentelles
Feature benutzen, was irgendjemand auf der
Köln-Mail-Nähefse gepostet hat.
Das wurde quasi bei Red Hat
entwickelt, das hat was mit Phones zu tun.
Und
das wurde halt von so einem Intern entwickelt,
der bei Red Hat gearbeitet hat
für ein paar Monate. Und
so habe ich mir die letzte Version gezogen,
hab das versucht zu applyen, das hat dann irgendwann
funktioniert, und dann
hab ich das versucht zu compilieren, und dann hab ich gesehen, okay,
so wie der Patch da gepostet
wurde, hat der nie compiled.
Also, und der wurde aber reviewt
von den Leuten, also die Leute reviewen halt irgendwie
Code, und ja, man ist das halt so,
ist halt sehr ungewohnt, man ist halt, mittlerweile ist man halt
so Standards gewöhnt, man hat jetzt irgendwie so irgendwas
GitHub-ähnliches. Bevor es nicht ein grünen Bild hat,
schau ich es mir gar nicht erst an.
Genau, genau, und
dort werden halt irgendwie so Sachen schon
reviewt und so, die werden nie
bauen.
Da habe ich dann irgendwie auch versucht, die Leute anzuschreiben,
um sie den Pitch nochmal nachschicken können, aber der intern,
der war schon irgendwie über alle Berge.
Ich habe dann von dem
von dem
seinem Chef quasi während des
Internships habe ich dann irgendwie nochmal Fixes bekommen,
damit es überhaupt kompiliert.
Das ist
einer der Gründe, warum das
Rast4Linus-Projekt gerne auf irgendeiner
der neuen Code-Plattformen bleiben würde. Aktuell
klar gesagt, dass wir nicht auf GitHub alleine,
dass es ein Bequemment für GitLab gibt,
nur dass wir gerne so ein System hätten.
Also GitLab ist da für uns auch okay.
Das gibt natürlich auch ein bisschen
Zoff in der
Linux-Kernel-Mailing-Liste, aber
bei uns ist auch ganz klar, dass du nach wie vor
halt die Patches per Mail einschicken kannst.
Aber eigentlich ist
für die alle, die GitHub haben,
viel einfacher. Dann kann man einfach PR machen,
sieht da schön diverse
Checklists. Am Anfang hat diese
CI auch nur sechs Stunden gebraucht.
haben wir mittlerweile mal ein bisschen fixen können,
dass es nicht so immer ganz so lange dauert.
Und ja.
Auch schön, eine Microsoft Subsidiary
als canonical hosting dafür hinzustellen.
Aber ich habe den Eindruck,
dass das quasi jetzt so die Opportunity ist,
nicht nur, dass mit diesem Projekt
man eine modernere Sprache in den Linux-Querl einsieht,
sondern auch modernere Arbeitsmethoden.
Wir haben so eine Plattform, wir haben CI,
wir schreiben Dokumentationen, wir sind freundlich.
Aua.
Also man muss auch dazu wissen,
wenn man auf so, also wie das aktuell organisiert ist,
man hat halt im Kernel-Subsystem so verschiedene Subsysteme.
Da gibt es zum Beispiel KVM oder da gibt es so Graphics
oder da gibt es dann für jede Artikatur,
hast du in der Regel ein Subsystem.
Und du musst dann erstmal, wenn du irgendwie ein Patch schreibst,
musst du erstmal rausfinden, okay, wo geht das jetzt eigentlich hin?
Also wen muss ich jetzt anschreiben?
weil wenn man, ja, also das war so meine erste Erfahrung,
mein erster Patch im Linux-Curnel.
Ich habe da irgendwas gemacht am Netzwerk.
Das war so ein Interface, was ich einfach zugefügt habe.
Ich habe das dann, weil das hat was mit Pritches zu tun,
das ist so ein Netzwerk-Feature,
habe ich das irgendwie an die Pritches-Mailing-Liste geschickt.
Und da kam dann erst mal nichts.
Da habe ich mir das dann aber noch mit auseinandergesetzt,
habe gesehen, okay, da gibt es jetzt noch mehr Mailing-Liste,
da gibt es zum Beispiel noch eine speziellere Native-Mailing-Liste.
habe ich dann da den Maintainer mit
gezeesied,
quasi mit dem E-Mail dahin
geschickt und dann wurde es dann noch
übernommen, dann ging es dann relativ schnell.
Also man muss erstmal rausfinden, wo schicke ich den
Kram hin und dann hast du halt irgendwie so,
ja, du brauchst erstmal ein elaboriertes
Mail-Setup, also du wirst auf jeden Fall
Filter haben, die diese einzelnen
Mail-Initze voneinander trennen, dass die nicht alle
in deiner normalen E-Mail-Inworks landen.
Ansonsten, wenn du so einen 0815
Mailer benutzt, dann
geht der halt in die Knie, weil der kommt halt
diesen ganzen Zehntausenden von E-Mails,
die sich da in kurzer Zeit ansammeln, kommt da einfach
nicht klar. Das heißt,
viele Leute, die sich dann damit mehr beschäftigen,
die gucken sich dann so Konsolen-Clients
an wie Mood oder
mittlerweile gibt es
so eine Art Mail-Index,
der heißt NotMatch,
wo dann die E-Mails einsortiert werden und
indiziert werden,
damit das Ganze überhaupt skaliert auf
was im Linkskörner so herumkommt.
Also es ist halt kein Witz. Also ich habe jetzt irgendwie
mich 4KVM auf die Mail-Index
vor zwei Wochen
subscribt und da sind bestimmt so ein paar tausend
E-Mails schon zusammengekommen.
Das ist immer so ein bisschen so ein Right of Passage,
kann ich mir vorstellen, dass man sich überhaupt
erstmal reinfuchsen muss. Mit wem muss ich reden?
Wo muss ich schreiben? Welchen
Ton muss ich finden, damit die Leute mich
überhaupt beachten oder so?
Ist das so?
Ja, es ist, wenn man
jetzt einen Patch checkt, ist das recht formell.
Also man muss halt das richtige
GIP-Kommando kennen, das diesen Patch
konfiguriert. Also meine Empfehlung wäre,
wenn man sowas macht, ist, oder das
Einfachste, was ich finde, ist
im Git
kann man, oder das sein Git kann man so konfigurieren,
dass es den Commits nimmt
und die als Patches
formatiert und dann in den
eigenen IMAP-Server als
Draft einbringt und dann kann man
von dort aus, wenn man dann den in seinem
Draft-Bot drin hat,
kann man von dort aus
kann man dann die Drafts bearbeiten und
kann sagen, okay, ich schicke jetzt mal die auf die Mailing-Liste.
Ich würde sagen, das ist so der einfachste Weg,
wenn man jetzt nie sich so
voll committen will auf den Command-Bezahlen
E-Mail-Client. Ich glaube, der
Standardweg ist quasi, dass man im
E-Mail-Client, man sagt man,
also sagt man Git-Format-Patch, ist also der eine Befehl,
der spuckt dann den Patch
als E-Mail-Formatiert, also wirklich so
als raw Plain-Text-E-Mail mit
Subtitles
und so weiter.
Wird das dann ausgespuckt und das
pipet man dann in den anderen Git-Command,
der dann Send-E-Mail ist und der schickt
das dann an die richtige Mailing-Gest. Das ist so normale,
das ist so der ursprüngliche
Workflow. Und
irgendwann, dieses ganze Pull-Quest
Feature, ich weiß nicht, also das will wahrscheinlich
die meisten nicht wissen, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Das kommt ja auch aus der
Curling-Mailing-Gest.
Und zwar, wenn der Patch dann irgendwann zu groß
wird, dass man den nie mehr komplett
als Patch senden will, wenn man zum Beispiel,
ich bin jetzt zum Beispiel Bluetooth-Maintainer oder so,
dann kriege ich ein ganzes Menge Patches rein und
irgendwann will ich meine Änderungen ja mal
an den Mainline-Curlern schicken,
also an Torwart, das ist quasi so eine Art hier,
wie das dann so hoch tropft.
Und dann wird dann so ein
Subsystem-Maintainer, der würde dann halt
Linus eine E-Mail schicken, okay, hier,
ich pull mal bitte von diesem Git.
Also das ist dann wirklich ein Pull-Request, ist dann eine E-Mail,
wo dann drin steht, okay,
pull mal bitte die folgenden Changes
von folgender Git-Revision.
Und das wird dann so formatiert von Git.
Und dann würde dann halt Torwart hingehen und dann
dieses von diesem Git pullen.
Das ist ja eine
Common-Misconsum,
Reception, dass das ein Pull-Request
ist. Deswegen heißen sie ja auf GitLab
dann noch Merge-Requests, was eigentlich der sinnvollere
Begriff ist.
Eigentlich muss dann, bevor das abgesendet werden kann,
das auch erst noch eine Woche auf Linux Next rum
baumeln, damit das dann
in Torwels gemercht werden darf.
Okay,
wird das da wenigstens irgendwie getestet
oder liegt das da einfach bloß rum, damit es ein bisschen reift?
Das liegt da rum,
damit es halt getestet werden kann und vor allen Dingen damit auch
alle Subsystem-Merches miteinander getestet
werden kann und gerne gibt sowas auch mal Merch-Konflicts.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
sitzt da sogar jemand rum und schaut die ganze Zeit,
gibt das Merch-Konflicts? Wenn ja, versucht
die Person das sogar zu fixen.
Schickt dann an die beiden
Trees, die den Merch-Konflict
haben, eine Mail.
Hier, das ist
der Possible Fix. Bitte
redet doch mal mit dem anderen Subtree, der das
Problem hat, um euch zu einigen,
wer jetzt das alles macht und wie
macht und im Endeffekt
ist ja Rast4Linux auch immer ein eigener
Ein-Eins-Tub-System. Aber das heißt
dann quasi, wenn mein
Code, mein Patch, den ich irgendwann
mal einreichen möchte und weiß Gott, ich werde
wahrscheinlich nie was an den Linux-Kolle
...
Wenn der diese ganzen Ochsen-Tour
durch ist, muss ich mir wahrscheinlich das komplett nochmal
selber dann wieder per
Rebase-Pool runterziehen und die
Änderungen, die seitdem drauf gemacht wurden,
wieder bei mir
reinziehen, damit es
doch jedes Mal ein ganz schöner Hässel, oder?
Ja, also wenn dann
irgendwie so ein Merch-Konflikt auftreten sollte,
oder beziehungsweise, wenn man so die
Iterationen macht, also bei
GitHub oder so sagt man ja einfach, okay, ich abdeh
jetzt meinen Pull-Quest einfach,
und dann hab ich da die neue Version drin.
Was dann beim Nierings-Könnel passiert ist,
du hast an diese Patches, oder wenn du
dieses Format-Patch machst, dann kannst du
daran auch noch eine Versionsnummer mitgeben.
Du sagst dann halt irgendwie Patch-Version V3
oder so, und du tust dann in deinem
in deinem V3, also wenn du dann so ein Patch hast,
wird er dann aus,
also jeder Commit ist dann quasi
eine andere E-Mail und du hast dann
irgendwie so eine Haupt-E-Mail, die das alles nochmal zusammenfasst
und wenn du dann verschiedene Versionen hast, dann sagst
du in der Regel auch noch, okay, in Version V3
habe ich jetzt noch folgende Sachen gefixt.
Weil der Code-Revier
funktioniert quasi so, du hast dann halt
für jeden Commit ist eine eigene Datei und die Leute, die
dann deinen Code kritisieren,
die tun dann halt inline
in den Patch-Sachen
kommentieren. Also die
die nehmen dann dieses Div,
was dann mit in dem Mailbody drin liegt
und schreiben dann so Inline-Kommentare da dran.
Ein Nachteil, den ich zum Beispiel sehe,
ist, dass zum Beispiel, du siehst,
du kannst ja nämlich bei GitHub sagen,
okay, jetzt gib mir mal mehr Kontext oder so,
ich muss jetzt mal mehr von der Datei lesen,
das geht ja dann lieber, das ist ja nur so eine E-Mail,
da steht ja auch der Patch drin.
Haben dann die E-Mail-Programme wenigstens
Source-Code-Highlighting oder sowas?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ja, es gibt,
hier ist der Typ,
i3 gemacht hat, wie hieß der?
Also es gibt wahrscheinlich irgendeinen.
Es gibt ein ARC
oder so, oder es gibt ja dieses andere,
es gibt so eine Kit-Hosting-Plattform,
die auf Mailing-Messen basiert.
Ja, die habe ich schon mal verwendet.
Ja, Sauce hat es mega.
Und
also die kümmern sich darum,
dass dieses ganze Workflow besser wird.
Also die haben da so ein paar Sachen eingebaut,
um das Erträgliche zu machen.
Unter anderem haben die einen neuen Mail-Client geschrieben,
der dann genau diese Features hat, die man auch braucht,
um an diesen Willemersen teilzunehmen zu können.
Wir bauen eine GitHub-Hosting-Plattform.
Lass mal einen Mail-Klein schreiben.
Ich meine, das hängt zusammen, klar, aber es ist auch ein schöner Gedanke.
Ein Vorteil von diesen alten Mailing-Listen ist natürlich irgendwie,
dass bei GitHub und GitLab die Psy läuft ja nur auf dem Head von deinem PR.
Und bei den Mailing-Robotern, hier der von Intel und so,
die App-Line das halt auf den aktuellsten Trees, soweit ich weiß.
hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass man da weiß,
das funktioniert mit dem aktuellen.
Und bei GitHub ist irgendwie nur so,
dass es mit dem Max aktuell hier drauf ist
und wir schauen, ob es einen Konflikt gibt.
Wenn es einen Konflikt gibt, dann zeigen wir das zwar rot an,
aber wenn es keinen Konflikt gibt,
dann wird das wohl schon funktionieren.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut, also jetzt haben wir uns ein bisschen verirrt,
wie ist eigentlich der Arbeitsablauf von Linux-Körner-Entwicklung.
Ihr habt jetzt gesagt,
Rust in Linux hat quasi
seine eigene
auf dem 21. Jahrhundert
basierende Hosting-Plattform und
macht das über GitHub
oder GitLab. GitHub aktuell.
Und da funktioniert es dann quasi dann so,
dass ihr auf dem entwickelt,
immer so ein bisschen hinterher seid,
da euren eigenen Linux-Fork habt
und dann alle paar so und so mal sagt,
hier, mach mal bitte Merch
in den Upstream vom
Linux-Körner oder wie ist der Ablauf da?
Mehr oder minder, genau. Wir haben dann
durch so einen riesen Pull-Request,
der ist dann so
5000 Files
Changed. Da steht dann, der heißt
dann auch einfach Sync
5.15
RC1 oder was auch immer.
Und damit machen wir dann einmal, dass wir es
aktuell machen und dann, ja.
Und muss das dann nochmal reviewt werden oder liest
auf eurem Branch
jemand mit aus dem
Mainline-Körnel und sagt dann
das okay so? Weil
vier Wochen, die ihr an dem Ding arbeitet, irgendwas
einschleichen und das dann mitmergen?
Das würde dann eventuell... Wir schicken dann
also am Endeffekt, wenn das dann wieder in den
Upstream werden soll, also wenn es in Linux
Next geht und auch danach in Linux selber
hoffentlich irgendwann mal,
dann machen wir auch wieder noch so
einen Check, einen Git-Patch
und da ist dann halt nur
die Rast-Changes drin, sprich
das wird dann reviewed und was wir machen,
da können wir auch alles mögliche machen, wir haben die kompletten
.github-Ordner mit drin, den brauchen wir
für die GitHub CI.
Das wird auch gar nicht mit committed.
Die Readme von uns wird nicht committed, wo halt so ein bisschen
GitHub-spezifische Dinge drinstehen.
Da stehen Rast-spezifische Dinge.
Das wird nicht mit committed, weil das interessiert auf Upstream
niemanden.
Sie haben also nicht mal eine Common History
in diese beiden Repos?
Doch, die Common History gibt es schon,
aber es gibt halt auf dem
Rast-for-Linux
gibt es Commits, die niemals
in dem Upstream-Linux
gemerged werden.
Ah, abgefahren.
Krass.
Da setzt sich dann Miguel immer hin,
irgendwie so ein bis zwei Tage,
kratzt alle
Patches raus, die dafür interessant sind,
sucht dann, wer hat diesen
Change gemacht, weil man muss ja auch immer
dieses
Certificate Eutschen heißt das, meine ich,
also dieses
Signed Off By, mit Zeile mit drin sein
und dann zum Beispiel Finn Behrens
und so muss das dann halt
alles dann formettiert werden
und dann geht das an die Mailing-Liste, wie das
andere auch.
Was ist denn jetzt momentan schon
Rust im Linux-Conway? Ist schon
irgendwelcher Code dabei, den ich
eventuell schon benutze?
Den du benutzen wirst, auf keinen Fall. Es ist noch gar
nichts gemerged. Es ist halt schon geschrieben,
ein Binder, der halt mehr
oder minder funktioniert. Da sind noch so ein paar
Dinge. Was ist ein Binder?
Ein Binder ist dieses Android Security
Framework Policy, IPC.
Ich hab's mir noch nicht so genau angeschaut.
selbst nutze mittlerweile auch keine Not mehr.
Und ich habe halt schon
noch einen PR offen liegen, der ist aber noch nicht mal
in dem Rast4Linux gemerged,
bin damit als Zwecktreiber geschrieben in Rast.
Also dieses
Binder ist quasi das, was
wenn man Android
ja zum Beispiel von eben Fenster auf ein anderes
Fenster zugreifen will, dann braucht man ja
oder zwischen verschiedenen Programmen, wenn die miteinander reden wollen,
wenn man zum Beispiel, ich habe jetzt einen Link
in dem Chatprogramm und will das jetzt in meinem Browser
öffnen, dann wird dann so ein Intent geschickt
und das macht Binder im Hintergrund.
der sorgt dafür, dass diese
Interprozesskommunikation funktioniert.
Also so ein High-Level-IPC quasi.
Genau, und so ist mit Depos unter Linux
ist dann Android-Spinder.
Hat auch nicht so viele Anhänger.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wer es geschrieben hat.
Linus oder Greg
oder irgendwie so jemand von denen, meine ich,
hatte das geschrieben, dass halt
dieses Binder nur versehentlich
im Linux-Kernel ist, eigentlich da gar nicht so wirklich hingehört
und vor allen Dingen gar kein gutes Beispiel für einen
Treiber geschrieben in Rast ist.
Ja gut, es ist insofern nicht wirklich ein Treiber
in dem Sinne, aber gibt es andere
Lighthouse-Projekte, wo man sagen könnte, das ist was, wo man mal ein Auge
drauf werfen könnte, das landet irgendwann in naher Zukunft
vielleicht im Linux-Körnel und ist Rust-basiert oder irgendwas, was ersetzt werden soll?
In eigener Sache. Ich habe noch vor, wenn dann die
ganzen Abstractions, die ich bis jetzt geschrieben habe und auch dieser Dummy-Treiber geschrieben ist,
will ich mich, wenn ich dann Zeit noch habe in dem Studium, weil es wird bestimmt
ein bisschen dauernd, bis das gemerged ist, will ich mich
an die 1000 setzen.
Kannst du das nochmal sagen, bitte?
Dann will ich mich an den E1000 setzen. Das ist dieser
Netzwerktreiber für Intel-Karten, für die alten.
Das ist vielleicht
gar nicht so alt. Also ich glaube,
wenn er zum Beispiel einen ThinkPad hat oder so,
hat häufig so ein
Intel-Nick drin und
dann hat man diesen E1000. Also der ist schon
sehr weit verbreitet, würde ich sagen.
Ja, er hat auch ein Chemo-Target, deswegen ist
er für mich interessant. Es gibt mittlerweile den
E1000E. Ich meine, der ist jetzt
Der hat jetzt diesen E1000 abgelöst,
soweit ich das verstehe.
Ich habe mir halt den E1000 angeschaut,
weil der nicht so kompliziert ist. Das sind glaube ich
10.000 Zeilen oder so NC, ungefähr.
Und
der hat halt vor allem den Chemo-Target,
sprich, dann kann ich das mit Chemo sinnvoll testen.
Chemo ist nur ganz kurz.
QEMU. Ach, QEMU.
Wir haben
Emulation
und Hypervisor.
Alles klar. Mit der Aussprache habe ich es dann auch erkannt.
Cool, und C-Lang meinst du?
Genau, so wie C-Lang.
Und Google hat quasi nur
Binder als Eisen im Feuer,
oder haben die noch andere Projekte?
Nein, sie haben ja irgendwie
über irgendwelche Umwege, soweit ich das
verstanden habe, da gab es einen Blogpost zu,
bezahlen sie irgendwie Miguel.
Und damit haben sie halt viele der Abstractions
mehr oder minder unter sich
entwickelt, auch wenn der Name nicht dran steht.
Ah ja, verstehe.
Google arbeitet ja eigentlich insgeheim auch bereits an Fuchsia.
Wisst ihr, ob es da irgendwelche,
was auch irgendwie zu 50% in Rust geschrieben ist,
wisst ihr, ob es da irgendwelche Cross-Pollinations gibt
zwischen diesen beiden Projekten?
Ich habe mich da ein bisschen mal mit Miguel und Wetzel unterhalten
und da ging es wohl nur darum,
dass das ein anderes Department von Google ist
und es mehr oder minder ein Rennen gibt,
wer ist erst fertig, wer kann erster Management überzeugen
und bis dahin gibt es beides.
Ich meine, es ist beides Open Source
und ich weiß jetzt nicht, welche Lizenz Fuchsia hat,
aber wenn die Lizenz passt, kann man ja sogar auch Dinge kopieren.
Keine Ahnung.
Würdest du noch was sagen, Jörg?
Ja, ich glaube, das Fuchsia-Projekt
an sich ist erstmal
ein bisschen transparenter teilweise.
Bei Android ist es ja so, wenn das
Android entwickelt wird, irgendwann gibt es eine neue Version
und dann schmeißt GitHub,
dann schmeißt Google erstmal wieder Code über den Zaun
und dann müssen
die ganzen Hersteller, die Hersteller
kriegen es glaube ich in der Regel früher, aber so
alternative Firmware wie
Lineage,
die kriegen das ja was noch später, die müssen
erst mal anfangen, das selber zu bauen und zu gucken,
was die jetzt geändert haben und ihr Zeug dann
anpassen darauf.
Ich glaube, bei Fuchsia
ist es ein bisschen offener, aber Google hat
noch viel mehr der Drücker drauf, also sie kontrollieren
alles, sie ist komplett der Gatekeeper für dieses
Betriebssystem.
Das ist wie ein Rattenschwanz
noch dran, das sehe ich krass.
Und bei Fuchsia
gibt es glaube ich keine offizielle Aussage,
ob das irgendwann mal ein Linux-Körnel für Android ersetzen soll
oder sowas wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist soweit ich weiß,
halt dieses Rennen, wer kann erst
sein Mensch mit überzeugen?
Ah ja, da bleiben wir doch durchaus gespannt.
Gehen wir
wieder ein bisschen zurück.
Kilian, fällt dir einfach so eine Frage ein zwischendurch,
die dir unter den Nägeln brennt?
Ich bin einfach fasziniert
von diesen Detailwissen.
Ja, super gut.
Dann gehen wir noch mal ein bisschen ins Technische rein.
Also wenn ich jetzt, ich habe selber ein paar Zeilen Rust geschrieben, aber eher sehr, sehr high-leveliges Zeugs oder Web-Services oder CLI-Tools.
Die Entwicklung von Kernel-Module ist ein ganz anderes Feld.
Was gibt es da für Besonderheiten, die wichtig sind zu wissen, wenn man jetzt jemand ist, der zwar schon Rust geschrieben hat, aber noch nie ein Körner-Modul gemacht hat? Wir haben vorhin gesagt, man kann zum Beispiel aufgrund des Bildsystems keine externen Dependencies momentan verwenden, aber was gibt es noch so für Einschränkungen?
Also normalerweise hast du ja, dass du das
STD-Lib hast, also dieses komplette
STD-Weg-Standard-Gibli.
Das gibt es alles gar nicht,
weil das dependet
halt auf Libc und damit auf Linux-Kernel
oder halt auf, wie auch immer das unter Windows heißt,
auf diese ganzen Dependencies.
Die gibt es halt im Linux-Kernel selber
natürlich nicht, weil wir sind schon der Kernel.
Sprich, jeder Treiber muss mit
No-STD heißt das dann in Rast
annotiert werden und ist damit
halt ohne dieses ganze Libc.
Was wir aber haben, was
in allen No-SDD-Projekten ist,
ist ein Allocator.
Sprich, du kannst schon wegnutzen,
das heißt dann aber halt nicht STD weg,
sondern das heißt dann Alloc weg.
Achso, die Standardbibliothek
von Rust wurde ja irgendwann mal aufgespalten
in mehrere Chunks, die man
unabhängig voneinander oder einigermaßen
unabhängig voneinander nutzen kann, sodass man
einen Subset...
Also du brauchst immer Core, also LibCore nennt sich das.
Core, das ist halt das Unterste,
das hast du immer, das kannst du nicht
loswerden. Wir werden aber sogar
von los. Das machen wir schon.
Dann gibt es halt Alloc.
Alles, was
Heap-Allokationen verwendet,
quasi. Genau das. Und dann gibt es
halt STD, was halt einen Kernel braucht,
der nicht er sich selber ist.
Was ist in STD zum Beispiel
drin, was auf einen Kernel zugreift,
was nicht in Alloc ist? Dateien.
Dateien, Netzwerk,
also was. Alles klar.
Der ganze Spaß hier gekramt.
Alles, was einem das Leben einfach
macht. Also, aber
das klingt erstmal ziemlich einschränkend,
aber wenn man so normale
System Procuring Languages wie C
benutzt, ist das halt schon
sehr, sehr high level, weil selbst wenn man
nur Core zur Verfügung hat,
hat man halt trotzdem so Sachen wie
Slices, also dass man irgendwie
über Speicherbereiche
indexen kann und dass
es dann aber trotzdem Memory safe ist,
also dass du nie Outbound gehen kannst.
Also man hat trotzdem schon mehr als ein C
selber überhaupt bietet. Oh ja,
und auch Overflows, also zum Beispiel
wenn du zwei Zahlen addierst und dann
wieder bei unter 0 rauskommst, also wenn du
quasi immer den Zahlenraum
immer überläufst,
da hast du halt in RAS viel besser
Absaktionen drin, wie du das handeln kannst,
dass du das checken kannst.
Also wenn ich was für einen
Linux-Körner schreibe, dann brauche ich eigentlich kein Netzwerk
und dann brauche ich auch kein Dateisystem,
weil das spreche ich eh über andere
Schnittstellen mit, das macht der Körner für mich
über andere Schnittstellen. Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwann
einen Rapper, der so einen Linux-Körner
FS für mich anbietet, dass sich das so ähnlich
anfühlt oder so. Aber es ist ja eigentlich nicht das, was ich machen will.
Ich möchte irgendwie mit einem
Netzwerkkarte
sprechen und da einfach bloß
irgendwie Bytes reinschreiben und Bytes rauslesen
wahrscheinlich auf eine gewisse Art und Weise.
Und dementsprechend ist es relativ
einfach
oder relativ hinreichend, was
ich mit Core kriege.
Zu diesen Overflows habe ich noch was Interessantes.
Das kann man nämlich abschalten. Also standardmäßig
ist es halt im Rast, dass es halt ist,
wenn ich in einem U8,
also in einem 8-Byte
255 plus 1-Rechen habe ich ein Overflow.
Und das kann man aber abschalten.
Das ist in Rast4Linux
eine Option für den Kernel
auch beim Bauen.
Diese Overflows
sind normalerweise ein Panic
in einem Debug-Bild und in einem
Release-Bild ist es dann einfach
quasi Antifight-Behaviour und du kriegst dann einfach wieder
eine 0 oder eine 1, wenn ich
überlaufe? Oder was passiert da?
Gute Frage.
Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht.
Ja, doch, doch.
Also in einem Debug-Build hat man dann seine Overflows,
was sehr praktisch ist.
Gerade wenn man im, ich glaube, im Linux ist es dann zwar nicht an,
aber wenn man zum Beispiel gerade im Linux-Körner,
wenn man dann irgendwie zwei Adressen radiert,
kommt man schnell mal über die,
overflowt man gerne und das dann richtig zu machen,
ist dann schon, ja, es geht häufiger kaputt,
Also wahrscheinlich hatte ich in der Vergangenheit viel häufiger Overflows,
habe die einfach auf mich mitgekriegt, dass sie passiert sind.
Und jetzt prescht mir einfach der RAS-Code weg.
Das ist schon echt hilfreich.
Dann gehen wir doch mal ganz kurz ein auf die Sachen,
die RAS da bietet, die eventuell im Linux-Kanal ein bisschen komplizierter sind.
Nehme ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt so ein Overflow produziere,
dann knallt mir der Code.
Und der RAS ist das eine Panic.
was was anderes ist als eine Exception,
ein C++ zum Beispiel. Ich weiß nicht, was würde
in C
in so einem Fall passieren?
Das ist dann einfach undefined behavior und das läuft
fröhlich weiter?
In C gibt es ja kein Overflow-Check.
Genau, da ist es dann einfach
passiert und es geht weiter.
Aber
wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
das Panic Handling in Rust ist ja schon
einer von den Aspekten der Sprache,
die eine gewisse Form von Runtime mitbringen.
Das heißt, der Code ist irgendwie
hat dann irgendwie
Aufräumcode mit eingebacken, der dann in dem Moment
richtig entweder den, also
normalerweise, wenn du eine Binary hast,
die Binary sauber aufräumt und
beendet. Was würde dann im
Körnelmodul passieren?
Es gibt das...
Ja, also aktuell ist das so,
es wird ein Panic-Händler
definiert im Rastkörnel,
also der macht dann, der mappt das
dann quasi auf so eine Körnel-
Funktion, die
dafür zuständig ist,
per Index zu printen quasi.
Also die Fehlermeldung kriegt man.
Da hast du eine Funktion und die kriegt das
und die printet das dann einfach fertig.
Genau, das System
crasht dann, also kann ja
nochmal was zu erzählen vielleicht.
Genau, also im Linux-Kernel haben wir es aktuell so,
dass das dann Kernel-Bug,
wenn sich das auslöst, das hat auch schon
Kommentare von,
ich meine, es war sogar Linus persönlich gegeben,
dass das vielleicht nicht die beste Idee ist,
weil es gibt ja einen Bug und Ups im Kernel
und kann zwar auch ein Bug sein,
aber es kann auch sein, dass dann nur das Modul
gekillt wird und der Rest vom Kernel weiterläuft,
was ja eigentlich für so einen Kernel schöner ist.
Können wir das mal kurz zusammenfassen? Es gibt einen Kernel
Bug und einen Kernel Oops. Gibt es nicht auch einen Kernel
Panic? Ich meine
Kernel Panic ist ein Kernel Bug, wenn ich mich gerade nicht irre.
Cool.
Also zumindest wenn man halt einen Bug ausführt, dann stirbt der
Kernel und sagt, ich will jetzt nicht mehr. Und wenn man halt ein
Oops ausführt, dann stirbt halt das Modul und der Kernel
läuft weiter.
Dieses ganze Panic ist aber
sehr unerwünscht im Kernel.
selbstverständlich, weil so ein Kernel abstürzen
oder auch schon ein Modul abstürzen zu lassen in einem Kernel
ist nicht so schön wie, hey, jetzt geht Systemd hin
und startet den Prozess neu,
weil es ist ein Systemd-Prozess fertig.
Das ist dann ein bisschen komplizierter.
Deswegen wird alles dran gemacht,
dass Panic überhaupt nicht ritten kann.
Unter anderem mussten wir
dafür Alloc neu bauen,
beziehungsweise verändern vielmehr.
Sprich, aktuell haben wir sogar ein eigenes Alloc
und nutzen nicht das von Rast selber.
Wir arbeiten zwar mit Upstream-Rast zusammen,
um das zu fixen irgendwann, aber aktuell
haben wir ein eigenes, damit halt, wenn der RAM voll ist,
unser Modul nicht abstürzt,
sondern eine Fehlermeldung zurückgibt und aber weiterlaufen kann.
Ich versuche mal ein bisschen Kontext zu geben, also
Alloc ist der Mechanismus
in der Sprache, der
dafür sorgt, dass man Speicher alloziert,
also dass man nur einen Heapspeicher alloziert.
In einem
normalen Rust Binary wird dafür
libc
Alloc verwendet,
oder bis vor einiger Zeit noch
jmalloc
wie es heißt. Und ihr habt
jetzt quasi für Rust im Linux-Kernel
ein eigenes Malog gebaut.
Ja, also wir gehen im Hintergrund
haben wir auch nur K-Malog, heißt das dann, glaube ich.
Das ist eine C-Funktion, die im Kernel
schon definiert ist. Aber
das Problem ist halt, die kann halt auch einen Fehler
zurückgeben, weil der RAM gerade voll ist. Also genau,
ein Allog kann einem um die Ohren fliegen,
wenn der speicherfeuer ist. Einfach. Das ist für den
normalen Fall. Genau.
Wenn ich ein neues Werk machen möchte und keinen Speicher mehr habe,
dann macht das halt einen Panic in einem
normalen Rust. Und das ist halt
sehr unerwünscht in einem Kernel, weil dann soll es
besser sein, wenn der Prozess einfach einen Fehler
zurückgibt, wenn das von dem User Space
angetreten ist oder
was auch immer. Und dafür haben wir
halt den iLog aktuell geforkt, haben
den im Tree sogar selber drin, dass wir da
gerade die Änderung machen können, arbeiten
mit dem Rast-
iLog-Team zusammen, dass das auch wieder
abgestreamt wird und dann gibt es irgendwann
das...
Was würde dann
passieren? Das würde dann einfach nicht
nicht paniken, sondern
du hast dann auf deinem
Alloc-Aufruf hast du quasi ein Result, was dir
einen Fehler zurückgibt mit, das geht jetzt einfach nicht.
Genau, wir haben dann das Feature
No Global Om Handling haben wir dann im Alloc an.
Das wird gerade noch in
Upstream implementiert. Om heißt
Out of Memory. Genau.
Und dann haben wir damit halt ein Result
zurück, weil dann gibt es nicht mehr die
Funktion VAC New, sondern VAC Try New
und das gibt dann Result zurück. Ah, ich würde gerade
sagen, es wäre ja ein Breaking Change, wenn das plötzlich
eine andere Signatur hätte. Das heißt, man
dann ist wahrscheinlich sowas wie
VAC-New im Linux-Körner auch einfach verboten.
Oder was passiert, wenn das in meinem Code vorkommt?
Das ist ein undefinites Symbol.
Mit No-Global-OM-Handling ist halt dieses auskommentiert.
Das ist ein CFG.
CFG No-Global-OM-Handling müsste dann an New dranstehen
und damit ist es dann weg.
Ah, das existiert also gar nicht in meinem RAS-Code.
Das würde gar nicht kompilieren.
Das ist sehr faszinierend.
Über was für ein Mechanismus ist das gelöst?
Ist das New dann Teil von Alloc und Try New Teil von Core?
Das ist beides immer noch von Alloc,
weil ich brauche ja trotzdem einen Allocator nicht irgendwo definieren muss,
den Global Allocator.
Es ist halt einfach nur ein anderes Feature-Flag.
Also es gibt ja dieses CFG in Rast-Z.
Ja, stimmt. Also gut, okay.
Dann ist das ein Feature-Flag.
Und wenn ich dieses Feature anmache,
dann habe ich quasi keinen weg New.
Ja, so ein anderes Rast-Feature, was auch sehr praktisch ist,
wenn man das in einem Betriebssystem hat,
ist dieses ganze Drop-Händler,
äh, Drop-Trade.
Also das ist im Prinzip ja dafür da,
dass wenn ein Objekt out of scope geht,
dann kann man irgendwie noch ein Stück Code ausführen,
der dann versucht, Sachen aufzuräumen.
Und das macht Fehlerbehandlung unglaublich viel einfacher,
weil der normale Use-Case oder der normale Workflow in C ist...
Das ist quasi ein Destructor,
nur ein bisschen Kontext mit dazu zu werfen.
Genau, das ist im Prinzip ein Destructor.
Da kann man zum Beispiel,
wenn man einen Destructor für eine File macht,
dann kann man sagen, okay, wenn dieses File out of Scope geht,
dann schließ das bitte.
Und das hat im News-Könnel
unglaublich,
führt zu unglaublich sauberen, mehr sauberen
Code, weil du kannst dann
normalerweise in C, wenn du dann
irgendwie Fehlerbeindungen machst, hast du dann
Goto-Labels, das ist so der Standardweg,
also du hast dann quasi am Ende deiner Funktion
hast du dann, okay, wenn diese Funktion quasi
wegen eines Fehlers zurück returnen
muss, dann geht die halt zu, macht die halt
Goto-Error zum Beispiel und dann in dem
Error-Label werden dann irgendwie
versucht, alle Ressourcen in der richtigen
Reihenfolge zu deallokieren.
Und wenn da der Fehler
vor allen Ressourcen machen
musst, dann hast du teilweise mehr Go-To-Label
zu schauen, welche Ressourcen kann ich überhaupt nicht machen,
welches noch gar nicht.
Du musst dann in deinem Kopf
überlegen, okay, aus
welchen Teilen deine Funktionen
quasi zurückspringen musst in diesen Error-Händler
und dann überlegen, okay, jetzt muss ich denen
die Ressourcen freigeben, die Ressourcen sind noch nie allokiert.
Also du hast dann mehr Error-Label
übereinander und die werden dann nach unten noch
abgearbeitet. Also es ist nicht schön.
Gibt es da irgendwie statische Analyse
für in C, die einem irgendwie hilft,
dass man da irgendwie die richtigen Zeilennummern
angibt oder die richtigen Labels?
Oh Gott.
Man muss natürlich auch in der richtigen freien Folge.
Ja, ja.
Einfach wichtig.
Ja, und RAS macht das einfach automatisch.
Also RAS hat man da einfach
mehrere Objekte, die werden gefreht,
sobald man rausgeht, da wird automatisch Code eingefügt,
der die Destruktoren aufruft
und ja.
Warum machen wir das überhaupt noch C?
Ja, das ist ein cooles Feature und das andere Feature ist, dass man das einfach so Data Erases, also wenn man parallel einen Code schreibt, dass das halt sehr viel besser und sehr in Rass gehandelt wird, dass du halt das sogenannte Aliasing quasi nie möglich ist, also dass du mit zwei Pointern auf den gleichen Speicher zeigst,
sondern quasi, dass du dann aus verschiedenen Threads zum Beispiel den gleichen Speicher schreibst und damit Bugs auslöst.
Sowas wird eben schon deutlich schwieriger gemacht, sodass du da eine ganz andere Obstraktion hast,
dass der Compiler da viel mehr Checks ausführen kann.
Dieses Drop kann man aber auch sehr schön nutzen.
Normalerweise hat man ja bei so einem Modul das Module Exit und Module Endit.
Module Endit ist einfach bei uns dadurch realisiert, dass man ein Trade implementieren muss.
Ich glaube, das Fate heißt dann Kernel-Modul oder so.
Und dann hast du da eine Funktion init.
Oder wie auch immer.
Ich muss dir jetzt nachschauen, wie die heißt.
Und für das Module Exit musst du einfach Drop implementieren.
Und das ist dann fertig.
Dann gibt es das auch.
Was will ich jetzt sagen?
Schön, dass du es gerade ansprichst, Jörg.
Mit Rust verhindert Data Races.
Das ist ja eines der ältesten Versprechen von Rust bereits.
Dass man durch den BorrowChecker die Möglichkeit hat,
zu verhindern, dass man von unterschiedlichen Threads
auf die gleichen Daten zugreift.
Und wie sieht denn jetzt momentan
Paralleles entwickeln oder Paralleles programmieren
im Linux-Körner mit Rust aus?
Seitdem, Rust gibt es ja jetzt fünf Jahre,
und von Anfang an hat man gesagt,
okay, du kannst jetzt von mehreren Threads
sicher auf die gleichen Daten zugreifen,
der Compiler garantiert das.
Aber seitdem ist ja noch ein bisschen mehr passiert
in der Rust-Entwicklung.
Mittlerweile gibt es Async-Await
und Runtimes mit dieser Art Green Threads anbieten
und Concurrent Programming an der Stelle.
Findet sowas schon irgendwie ein bisschen Einzug in den Nux-Körnel?
Ist das überhaupt interessant?
Ist das überhaupt irgendwann möglich?
Oder muss man dazu noch irgendwie solche Runtimes modifizieren?
Oder ist das alles noch Zukunftsmusik?
Ist das überhaupt ein Thema?
Also es gibt durchaus andere Brass-Projekte,
die sowas mit Async-Avade
experimentieren.
Und es hat auch dann Vorteile,
es macht auch Code teilweise schneller,
dadurch, dass du zwischen
verschiedenen Kontexten schneller hin und her switchen kannst.
Aber ich glaube, im Linux-Kernel
wird es wahrscheinlich einfach
die Infrastruktur verwenden, die der
Rust-Kernel schon, also dieses,
die der Kernel schon mitliefert, also das ist eine Art
Fretz. Ich finde es schön, dass du mal Rust-Kernel
sagst.
Der Linux-Kernel meinst du wahrscheinlich.
Der Linux-Kernel, ja.
Von Arsting-Await habe ich noch gar nichts gehört,
dass das irgendwie verwendet werden soll.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht der Plan.
Was gerade unter anderem implementiert wird,
beziehungsweise es läuft schon, aber es wird noch weiter daran gearbeitet,
ist sowas wie Spin-Lock.
Dass wir die Spin-Locks und Mutex und all sowas haben.
Mutex gibt es auch schon fertig.
Mutex kann man momentan noch gar nicht verwenden in Rust, oder wie?
Doch, sie sind fertig.
Also man kann Threads verwenden, man kann Mutex verwenden,
man kann Logs verwenden.
Ich weiß gerade nicht, wie man Threads verwenden kann,
aber man kann Mutex schon verwenden.
Und ich meine, soweit ich mich erinnere, sind das sogar einfach
die 10 Mutex, sprich du kannst das auch
aus C-Code dann, wenn das bestehende
das Mutex ist oder so, auch verwenden.
Muss man dafür dann komplett neue Bindings schreiben?
Oder ist das Teil von der...
Also das ist Teil von dem
Kernel-Crate,
mehr oder minder-Crate, was wir gebaut haben
als Rast-Vornieungsprojekt.
Und gerade arbeiten wir halt an Spin-Logs,
die dann sogar den Interrupt-States
saven können.
So was wie
so was wie std,
sync, mutex
und guards,
ist das in Core nicht vorhanden?
Hat man das einfach nicht?
Das ist in Core nicht vorhanden, weil zum Beispiel
das Rast std mutex, das
geht auf den Kernel, weil es natürlich
versucht nicht einen Spinlog zu machen, sondern
den Prozess dann abzugeben,
damit ein anderer Prozess arbeiten kann, damit der
Rechner schon schnell ist.
Und in dem Kernel ist das halt nicht so
und du hast dann im
Kernel halt so was wie ein Spinlog,
was das macht und damit kannst du das dann ganz so machen.
Also man kann durchaus im Rastkörnel,
im Linux-Körnel auch normale Logs implementieren.
Das wird sich durchsetzen.
Ja, es wird ein Rastkörnel irgendwann.
Es wird die Übernahme.
Es wird so ein Ebelplan, das ist jetzt leider rausgekommen.
Die, also Spin-Logs werden häufig gerne verwendet im Linux-Körnel,
weil es halt sehr performanceorientiert ist und manchmal hat man so
kleine kritische Section und
die Leute optimieren halt alles zu Tod und deswegen
werden dann halt häufig Spinlogs verwendet.
Aber es gibt auch durchaus eine Möglichkeit,
dass man so einen Log macht, wie man
das aus dem User Space kennt, wo dann quasi
der aktuelle Thread abgegeben
wird und der Kernel dann sich mit etwas anderem beschäftigt.
Also ein Spinlog ist wirklich quasi
Busy Waiting. Ich habe ein While und prüfe
immer wieder, bis meine Bedingungen
erfüllt ist oder was ist ein Spinlog?
Genau.
Genau, wenn ich irgendwie,
ich will jetzt irgendwie zum Beispiel
bloß eine einfache Datenstruktur manipulieren
und es ist jetzt nicht sehr wahrscheinlich,
dass es jetzt Conjection gibt,
also dass ich jetzt versuche mehrere darauf zuzugreifen,
das ist dann halt häufig sinnvoll,
dass man einfach einen Spinlog macht,
dass man einfach guckt,
okay, wenn jetzt jemand anders da ist,
dann warte ich halt so lange,
bis er seinen Schreibt.
Das ist, wenn ich auf I.O. warte oder wie?
Auf I.O. warten nie,
also meistens sind es Datenstrukturen,
auf die man schreibt.
Also du wirst halt in diesem, wenn du ein Spinlog immer genommen hast, dann wirst du halt möglichst nichts machen, was irgendwie blockieren könnte. I.O. zum Beispiel könnte blockieren, deswegen muss man dafür andere Startstrukturen.
Sowas wie das RTL ist zum Beispiel, also welche gerade die Netzwerkgeschichten, das ist mit Spinlog. Interessant dabei ist, dass im C der Spinlog immer extern vom Datentyp ist, sprich du musst den Spinlog holen, den Datentypen verarbeiten, den du auch ohne Spinlog verarbeiten kannst und release den Spinlog dann wieder, dabei kannst du natürlich vergessen, den Spinlog zu holen, zu releasen, was auch immer.
In Rust hat, ich weiß gar nicht, war ich das sogar?
Irgendjemand von uns hat das so implementiert,
dass wir da einen Guard auch drum haben,
so wie du es aus dem SED-Mutex kennst.
Genau, und in Rust ist ein Guard so eine Art Container-Typ.
Genau, und da kannst du dann halt einfach,
du holst dir den Datentyp mit einer Log-Funktion,
die auf dem Mutex-Typ implementiert ist,
kriegst einen Guard zurück,
und in dem Drop von dem Guard ist dann das Release drin,
sprich, wenn es gedroppt wird, hast du einen Release.
Du kannst erst darauf zugreifen, wenn du es Guard hast,
weil du sonst gar nicht an den internen Typen rankommst.
weil es halt einfach abstrahiert ist.
Und du hast einen Typ-Parameter dran stehen, dass du hinterher genau weißt,
was du da für ein Datenobjekt rausbekommen hast.
Ja.
Ah ja, krass.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich nur noch mal ganz kurz zu dieser
Async-Await-Geschichte zurückkommen, hauptsächlich
weil ich es interessant fand, weil
das ja offenbar sehr intensiv
im Fuchsia-Projekt verwendet wird.
Also es gab auf dem
Rustfest Barcelona,
ich werde das mal in die Shownotes hinzufügen,
einen Vortrag von einem der Fuchsia-Entwickler darüber,
wie Async Await in Rust super interessant
für Betriebssysteme in der Entwicklung sein kann.
Deswegen hat mich interessiert,
ob das vielleicht auch schon Einzug in den Linux-Corner an der Stelle zieht
oder ob es gesteigertes Interesse daran gibt, das zu verwenden.
Ich glaube, den Tag muss ich auch mal sehen.
Ich weiß von keinem Interesse.
Ja, also das könnte im Linux-Corner auf jeden Fall auch interessant sein,
aber da müsste wahrscheinlich dann die Akzeptanz von Rust auch größer werden
und es müssten auch mehr Sachen in Rust geschrieben sein.
und zwar gibt es auch im Minus-Kernel
sowas, so eine Art Task-Queue, sage ich jetzt mal.
Also du wirst, wenn du
im
Kernel bist, dann wirst du ja nie immer
Kontext-Switche machen, um zwischen
einzelnen Tasks, die du da so hast. Zum Beispiel sagst,
okay, jetzt habe ich mal wieder irgendwas vom Netzwerk
gefunden, jetzt habe ich wieder mal ein paar Netzwerk
Pakete, die ich verarbeiten will oder jetzt ist
meine Festplatte fertig und deswegen tut man
sowas in so kleine Tasks
queuen, also die dann aber
wie eine Art, ja, die werden dann einfach
von einer Funktion, die durch diese
Queue durchgeht, die werden dann halt nacheinander abgearbeitet
und sowas könnte man wahrscheinlich auch mit Async
Await implementieren,
aber ja, ich glaube, das wird
wahrscheinlich nicht kommen, weil das wäre halt zu sehr
ein zu tiefer Eingriff in die News-Könne.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass
andere Betriebssysteme
da mehr
Spielraum haben, sowas einzubauen.
Also EpoL mit Async Await
ist wahrscheinlich noch weit hinaus.
E-Pol-Evate. Ja, E-Pol.
Der Linux-Con implementiert E-Pol, deswegen braucht man
im Königskon lang kein E-Pol-Evate mehr.
Okay, cool.
So, ich
schaue mal ganz kurz in meine Notizen.
So, jetzt haben wir
eine Weile über Linux geredet, aber Betriebssystementwicklung
ist ja für
oder Rust ist ja auch für Betriebssystementwicklung
schon längere Zeit ein Thema und bevor das
einigermaßen feasible
Rust im Linux-Körner mit zu verwenden,
wie wir das jetzt besprochen haben.
Gab es ja auch andere Projekte.
Ich habe jetzt den Link nicht im Kopf.
Es gibt diese wunderschöne
US-Dev-Seite von irgendeinem Typen,
der so Blogposts darüber schreibt,
wie man Betriebssystem ist.
Und das auch häufig
einem Rust-Beispiel macht.
Und es gibt auch bereits ein komplettes
Betriebssystem, was komplett
von vorne in Rust gebaut ist,
nämlich Redox.
Hat das irgendeine
ist für den,
für Rust in Lilux?
Wie verhält sich das,
wie verhält sich das zueinander?
Ist das was, wo der eine vom anderen was abschauen kann?
Ist das architektonisch komplett anders?
Könnt ihr da ein bisschen was zu erzählen?
Also Retox an sich ist erstmal
ein Mikrokörnel,
also im Prinzip so wie,
ja,
so wie man es an der Uni lernt,
wie man eigentlich ein Betriebssystem bauen sollte,
was man aber in der Praxis dann doch wiederum
keiner macht, weil es halt in der
Vergangenheit immer wieder Probleme gab
mit Overheads,
wenn man so kleine
Mikrokodile baut.
Redox-S fühlt sich eigentlich
so, als ich das
zum ersten Mal benutzt habe, weil ich das
vor allem gestartet habe, da war ich
erstmal überrascht, wie viel die da eigentlich da eingebaut haben.
Also die haben da so eine komplette kramische Oberfläche,
die da aufpoppt. Es läuft leider nie
auf, oder es läuft mittlerweile
auch auf echte Hardware, aber sehr beschränkt.
Also der normale Anwendungsfall ist, dass du das vor allem entwickelst oder so weiter daran machst.
Und ja gut, also damit ist es halt nie wirklich sehr praktikabel für den täglichen Einsatz.
Allerdings gibt es viele so kleine Projekte, die aus diesem Redox OS rausfallen,
wo ich zum Beispiel die Libc ab und zu mal mir angucke.
Und zwar haben die eine Libc gebaut in Rust.
Also normalerweise ist eine Libc in C geschrieben.
Und das ist ganz praktisch, wenn man an Sachen arbeitet,
wo man keine Libc folgen will.
Weil dann kann man sich so...
Wenn man sich da Teile rausklauen.
Genau, genau.
Wenn man mal schnell einen Mem-Copy braucht oder so,
da kann man mal gucken, okay, wie haben die das da gemacht.
Ich habe nämlich zum Beispiel,
ich habe mal einen Linkloader geschrieben in Rast.
Das ist ein Programm, was man benutzt,
um dynamische Programme zu linken.
Also, dass man Libraries benutzen kann.
das ist im Linker implementiert
und ja, also
das ist halt auch wieder alles schön
dokumentiert und lesbarer Code
es gibt auch zum Beispiel
so eine Shell, die die implementieren
die Ion Shell oder so, die kann man dann auch auf
anderen Betriebssystemen in der Regel benutzen, so wie
die Libc
also es fallen halt so ein paar Praktik raus
die halt so wiederverwendbaren
Code haben, den man auch auf anderen Plattformen
finden kann, das ist ganz praktisch
Wenn es jetzt bereits eine Libc in Rust gibt, was denkt
ihr dann, warum
mein Standard-Rust-Compiler, wenn ich
was baue, die nicht bereits verwendet?
Man kann gegen
Muzzle linken, kann man auch gegen die
sein Programm linken? Geht das einfach?
Und das dann auf Linux
laufen lassen?
Ich glaube, die Relip-C funktioniert auf
Linux. Ich habe noch nie
versucht. Das ist, glaube ich, einfach ein
Crade. Wahrscheinlich kann man die dann einfach importieren
und legt dann alles raus.
Ja, ich habe jetzt noch
keinen, ich weiß nicht, wie
vollständig die ist. Also häufig hat man ja das Problem,
dass es dann so gewisse Inkompetibilitäten
gibt.
Das ist ja auch häufig, wenn man zum Beispiel
Muscle-Stallab-G-Lip-C benutzt, dann muss man halt
irgendwie, es gibt so ein paar Projekte, die
sind halt inkompatibel, da muss man anfangen zu patchen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie
das Baby-Lip-C aussieht.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Finder, hat da gerade noch was?
Redox ist halt generell so ein, lass uns alles in
Rast schreiben und wir machen alles neu,
machen alles so, wie man es in der Uni lernt,
Mikrokörnel. Gut, das werde ich jetzt
demnächst erst mal mir anschauen, wie man das in der Uni lernt.
Und das ist halt für Rast von Linux
definitiv nicht das Ziel. Das Ziel
ist einfach nur zu dem Bestehenden
die Möglichkeit geben, Rast zu schreiben.
Und auch am Anfang ist auf jeden Fall ganz klar,
dass man nur Treiber in Rast schreiben
darf, weil halt Rast noch nicht überall
kompiliert und damit der Linux-Körnel weiter
überläuft, auch in den neuesten Versionen.
Und erst wenn es dann GCC-RS gibt
oder so, da dürfen auch Subsysteme in
Rast geschrieben werden, außerhalb dem Rast-Subsystem.
Ich dachte jetzt nicht daran, dass man quasi den Linux-Körnel, Rust-Körnel wie Jocki nennt, durch Teile von Redox ersetzt, sondern auch so ein Projekt wie Redox wird ja wahrscheinlich schon seine eigenen Treiber für diese oder jene Hardware gebaut haben. Vielleicht könnte man ja davon Teile an den Linux-Körnel anschließen. Also was ist das, was interessant ist oder ist das eher unnötig?
Habe ich noch nicht reingeschaut. Das Problem dabei ist halt, dass du beim Linux-Kernel natürlich sowas wie XDP und diese ganzen Interfaces implementieren möchtest.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob Redox die auch hat. Also das ist dieses BPF-Ding.
Könntest du eventuell, wenn du solche Abkürzungen verwendest, ganz kurz sagen, was die bedeuten für die anderen? Zum Beispiel auch für mich.
Ja, muss ich nur darüber legen. Ich meine, XDP steht für Express Data Path. Das ist halt dafür da, damit du in so einem Kernel-Modul lastest, mehr oder minder.
oder das ist dieses F-Berkeley-Packet-Filter,
heißt das meine ich,
die du filtern kannst.
Genau, das ist eine Jitsprache, soweit ich weiß.
Ach so, um das vielleicht mal runterzubrechen.
Wenn du versuchst,
einen Treiber zu portieren
von irgendeinem anderen Betriebssystem auf Linux,
wirst du da sehr viele Probleme haben,
dass irgendwie APIs einfach komplett anders funktionieren.
In die andere Richtung wird es tatsächlich
gemacht, weil viele Leute wollen
Linux-Treiber benutzen, weil es gibt zu viele davon.
Deswegen hast du
bei verschiedenen Projekten hast du dann
Leute, die bauen dann halt Teile der Linux-Kernel-Treiber-API nach,
damit der Treiber dann noch auf anderen Plattformen läuft.
Zum Beispiel von Dresden.
L4-Linux oder sowas.
Genau, von Dresden, das L4-Linux-Projekt,
die haben dann auch teilweise Kernel-Treiber,
die sich aus dem Linux-Kernel-System borken können.
Das ist ja genau falsch rum.
Da hat man ja einen C-geschriebenen Treiber in einem sicheren System.
Aber gut, okay.
Cool. Sind euch sonst noch irgendwelche anderen unabhängigen Betriebssysteme-Projekte bekannt, die ja auch nennenswert sind in diesem Frontex?
Ja gut, wo wir eben drüber schon gesprochen haben, war Fuchsia. Aber ich glaube, da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen.
Genau. Also Fuchsia, komplett eigenes Betriebssystem, ist wahrscheinlich auch ein Mikrokörnel, oder wisst ihr das?
Ja, vielleicht. Vielleicht auch nicht, weil es ja pragmatisches Projekt sein könnte.
Ich meine, eben hat man irgendwo was von Mikrokörnel gelesen, aber ich bin nicht mehr sicher.
Gut, das lässt sich vielleicht noch nachtragen.
Was auch spannend ist, was mir vorhin als Frage eingefallen ist,
ich meine, klar, wir reden jetzt über Rust im Rust-Körner,
im Linux-Körner.
Und das ist natürlich besser als C,
deswegen möchte man es verwenden.
Aber sagen wir mal ehrlich,
Sprachen, die besser als C sind, gibt es doch schon länger.
Warum gibt es nicht schon länger Projekte,
die versuchen, C++ in den Linux-Körner einzubetten
oder Ähnliches.
Oder Haskell.
Warum ist es jetzt plötzlich bei Rust interessant?
Und warum ist das nicht schon früher mit C++ passiert?
Habt ihr da eine Idee?
Also da gibt es von C++ zum Beispiel,
gibt es von Linus Torwals genügend Antworten,
warum er C++ nicht mag.
Also das hat schon
ideologische Gründe.
Da sind wir sicher auch nicht
am Projekt dabei.
Ja, also
C++, man kann da mit euch
als Betriebssystem schreiben. Es gibt zum Beispiel
Serenity.
Ja, Serenity
OS, also da gibt es so lustige
YouTube-Videos, wo quasi der
Hauptentwickler, das ist quasi so eine Art
Hobby-Betriebssystem und der
baut halt sein Betriebssystem
da in irgendwelchen YouTube-Streams
und dann kann man denen dann über die Schulter gucken,
wie er da C++ verwendet, um so Betriebssysteme zu entwickeln.
Das klingt ja schon nach Tempel US fast.
Ja, genau.
Oder die L4-Projekte aus der Uni in Dresden
sind ja auch alle in C++ gebaut.
Genau.
Und das hätte ja auch ein paar Vorteile,
weil dann könnte man,
C++ hat halt mehr höhere Abstraktionslevel,
man könnte dann zum Beispiel im Kernel,
der auf macOS läuft,
dem Xnube-Kernel wird das ja zum Beispiel
verwendet, um eine stabile Treiber-AP
anzubieten, also da ist das
quasi das Interface nach außen, das ist in C++,
damit können dann die Hersteller hingehen und
ihre Treiber bauen für
macOS und
intern im Xnube
selber ist es dann aber wieder hauptsächlich
C.
Das ist aber auch fast wie
beim XNU ist es aber auch fast wie eine Mikrokernel, also
das Driver-Kit ist das jetzt, was zum Beispiel da für Treiber
interessant ist, das ist ein C++-Ding
und das ist halt nur, das ist ein Userspace-Prozess,
der dann halt über C++ irgendwelche Buffers, Streams,
was auch immer bekommt, um das zu machen.
Aber im Linux-Körnel ist C++ jetzt einfach nicht gelandet,
weil der Linus Torvalds da irgendwie keinen Bock drauf hatte?
Weil ich meine, die Gründe, die dafür sprechen, es zu verwenden,
sind ja ähnliche, wie die dafür sprechen, Rust zu verwenden.
Man hat ein höheres Abstraktionslevel,
man hat gewisse Sicherheitsmechanismen drin,
man kann vielleicht schönere APIs auch für Treiber-Entwickler anbieten.
Also wieso hat jetzt plötzlich Rust diesen Dammbruch geschafft,
als erstes nach 30 Jahren, nach fast 30 Jahren,
als erste neue Sprache irgendwie im Tree vom Linux-Körner aufgenommen zu werden?
Noch ist es nicht gelandet.
Nur im Linux Next.
Ja, also ich könnte mir einfach den Rand verlinken, wo Torwald sich über CIRS-Bus beschwert.
Schick mal den Link bitte her.
Ich kann immer durchlesen.
Weil das würde vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen das sprengen.
Okay, dann nochmal ganz kurz zu dieser Timeline, weil Finn gerade gesagt hat, das ist erst im Linux Next und noch nicht im Linux Tree.
Wie schaut es denn aus?
Besteht auch die Möglichkeit, dass irgendeiner zum Schluss sagt, nee, das machen wir jetzt nicht?
Und dann ist eure ganze Arbeit umsonst gewesen?
oder? Die Möglichkeit besteht bis zum Ende, ja.
Und gibt es da irgendwie
ein Zeitfenster, wo man
sagen könnte, also bis da und da liegt es
in Linux Next und irgendwann
wird es dann gemerged,
liegt es in Linux Next und wird dann
selektiv erst in den
Torvalds
Tree gemerged, bis es dann
wirklich im offiziellen Linux-Körner angekommen ist?
Wie läuft das ab?
Was sind eure Erwartungen noch?
Was ist als nächstes passiert?
Also zum einen selektiv ist es unter anderem schwierig,
einen Ordner zu haben, der gar nicht kompiliert,
weil der Mac-Fall noch nicht selektiert wurde,
ist irgendwie auch unwitzig.
Prinzipiell ist auf jeden Fall die Idee,
dass das Standardmäßig erstmal deaktiviert ist,
weil es einen mehr oder minder unstable Rast braucht
und so weiter und so fort.
Das Ganze ist aktuell, hängt das vor allen Dingen daraus,
dass viele sagen, wir wissen noch gar nicht,
ob es geeignet ist.
Wir haben zwar den Binder-Treiber,
aber dieses Android-Binder ist ja gar kein richtiger Treiber
und dass das im Kern überhaupt erstmal gelandet ist,
auch die C-Variante ist in versehen,
mehr oder minder. Und damit ist halt
dieses Bein da,
gefällt dem nicht.
Das Dummy ist halt noch nicht im Rast
vor Linux-Tree gemerged, sprich, das ist
zwar mal auf der Mailing-Liste drüber gegangen, dass es
da auch einen Dummy-Treiber gibt, aber das
ist auch nur ein virtueller Treiber, da ist 200 Zeilen
oder so, vielleicht auch so 150,
bin grad nicht mehr sicher.
Also das Einzige, was momentan
wirklich ein User davon ist, ist dieser versehentlich
gemergede Google-Code und ansonsten
so ein paar Toy-Projekte, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
ja, genau
und die Idee ist halt, also
viele von der Mailingliste wollen, dass das mit NVMe
gemacht wird, weil NVMe ist so einfach
es sind nur 500 Zeilen Specs
kann man sich drüber
ist das Datenbos, meine ich
für SSD
also NVMe kann ich was dazu sagen
weil da habe ich ein Forschungsprojekt drüber gemacht
NVMe ist quasi
eine Schnittstelle
mit der man mit
Flash-Speicher
reden kann und zwar
ja, geht das über PCI,
über den PCI-Bus.
Und ja, das ist das Schöne an dem
Interface ist, dass man damit viel Hardware, also
viel verschiedene Geräte
ansprechen kann, weil das alles
durchstandardiert ist. Ist das auf dem Level von
USB so ein bisschen, um mal einen Vergleich
zu bieten?
Ja, USB ist wahrscheinlich dann noch höher, weil mit USB
kann man dann alle möglichen Geräte bauen, mit
MVMI kann man wirklich bloß Speicher
addizieren.
Und damit kann aber, mit E-Mustreiber kann man
dann halt wirklich viel der Geräte ansprechen, das können
viele Leute testen, deswegen ist das ein ganz gutes Subsystem
oder ein ganz guter Treiber, um
Source zu testen. Und dann, ja, im Prinzip
wollen die halt einfach ein Proof-Konzept sehen,
ob sich Rast jetzt lohnt, oder
wie man das benutzen sollte auch,
weil, also man lernt ja
quasi immer von anderen Beispielen, also
wenn ich irgendwas im Linux-Körner implementiere, gucke ich
mir an, okay, so haben das andere Leute gemacht,
weil da gibt es einfach so viel Code, irgendein
Beispiel gibt es immer.
Genau, und denen fehlt halt einfach ein
Beispiel, um mit Hardware wirklich zu reden.
NVMe ist da von vielen
weil sie sagen, das ist so einfach.
Redstone hat jetzt gerade vor kurzem
einen GPIO-Treiber gedroppt,
mit Vergleich, wie es in C aussehen würde,
auf der LWN-Seite.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es genau war,
zumindest ist auch die Arbeit an dem
Random Numbers Generator
auf dem Raspberry Pi gewesen,
dass das irgendwie hoffentlich funktioniert,
dass man den in Rust hat, den Treiber,
weil Rust läuft ja auch auf dem Raspberry Pi.
Und ich will halt, sobald die Abstractions
dafür kommen, dann mal versuchen,
den E1000 zu schreiben.
Das ist ja auch richtige Hardware,
die man auch virtualisieren kann, was es halt viel einfacher macht
zu debuggen. Ah ja, also solche Projekte
sind schon geplant und
jetzt muss noch jemand irgendwie das Elbow Grease
investieren, um die
nochmal runter zu coden und
dann ist noch eine
Dependency quasi, ein Blocker wäre
quasi, dass man irgendwann vielleicht
einen stabilen Rust Compiler
verwenden kann, damit man nicht mit einem
was 10 Versionen alten
Beta Compiler weiterarbeiten muss.
Genau, so prinzipiell den Beta
nutzen wir auch nur für Features, soweit ich weiß.
ist das Unstable auch
dann schon wieder gelockt. Das
unlocken wir für sowas wie das Alloc-Crate,
weil das Alloc kann man nur mit Unstable bauen
über eine Umgebungsvariable, das ist
Voodoo-Magic
im Rust-C. Achso, man kann
das Alloc-Crate nur
auf einem Beta benutzen, weil man nur
dort Unstable Rust-Features verwenden kann.
Nee, man kann es eigentlich
nur auf dem Unstable nutzen, es gibt aber
Umwege, um das
mit einer Umgebungsvariable, das Unstable
auch in einem Stable-Rust zu unlocken.
Ah, okay. Aber wie sieht es an der Front aus?
Wie aus dir jetzt reich ist es, dass der Code,
den ihr da ändern musstet oder der dafür die Linux-Arbeit
geändert werden musste, auf Rust-Stable landet
oder auf Rust-Mainline landet?
Wir sind mit zwei, drei oder vier, ich bin gar nicht mehr sicher,
von dem Rust-Team im Gespräch andauernd.
Das ist halt alles auch eine langsame Mühle.
Da muss BOS immer alles checken.
Das muss natürlich ein RFC in der Regel gehen bei Rust.
Deswegen haben wir aktuell einen Fork von Alloc.
Aber generell wird Alloc immer unstable bleiben,
aber das kann man halt anlocken.
Ah ja, cool.
Immerhin musst du es nicht durch eine Mailing-Liste schieben,
an der Stelle.
Genau, denn Rust ist auf GitHub alles.
Ja, nice.
Also ich habe da schon,
ich muss sagen, ich finde das super vielversprechend.
Nicht nur, weil man Rust für Linux-Entwicklung nutzen könnte,
sondern weil ich mir auch so ein bisschen davon erhoffne,
dass es die Linux-Entwicklung an sich ein bisschen modernisierend könnte.
Alles, was man jetzt in Rust neu für Linux bauen würde,
würde wahrscheinlich nicht über Mailing-List-Patches vornehmlich gemacht werden,
sondern auf einem anständigen CI, einem anständigen System.
Und dann erst zum Schluss im Linux-Körnel landen per Mailing-Liste.
Nicht wirklich. Das ist so nur für die Abstractions.
Also alles, was in dem Ordner Rust liegt, ja.
Wenn ich aber jetzt zum Beispiel den E1000 schreibe und das Rast dann bis dahin schon gemerged ist, dann kann ich das nicht mehr mit dem Rast-Tree machen, weil dann ist der Rast-Ordner ja schon in der App-Stream drin.
Und dann ist das ein normales Liste an die Treiber-Entwickler für Netzwerke.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Aber im Endeffekt machen es wahrscheinlich dann Leute so, die das professionell machen und das ist nicht, wenn Google seine eigenen Treiber für Android entwickelt, die werden dann eine eigene CI für haben.
und das dann nur, um es zu abspielen.
Spätestens hast du ja als Entwickler
in der Regel, dass du es auch noch mal mindestens
baust, eigentlich auch testest.
Bis auf den Patch,
den Jörg da gesehen hatte.
Stimmt, kein Einzelfall.
Schwarze Schafe gibt es immer. Es gab ja
jetzt auch gerade den Skandal mit der
Universität Minnesota.
Stimmt. Das habe ich auch schon mal
vor zwei Folgen angesprochen.
Deswegen wundert mich, dass das so was
Weckruf ist, mal die Arbeitsabläufe
vom Linux-Körnel irgendwie in Frage
zu stellen und zu modernisieren,
weil das ist, auf die Art und Weise
ist es ja eigentlich
angreifbar, dass das überhaupt
möglich ist. Man kann auch heutzutage
so viel schon wegautomatisieren, dass
man diese menschlichen Fehler
Das kannst du aber genauso
auf der CI machen und es ist ja,
soweit ich weiß, sind die Patches von der
Minnesota auch über das Skylars oder wie auch
immer das Google-Projekt heißt gelaufen, also den
Syscall-Faser.
das ist halt das
was, die haben sich ja schon ein bisschen Mühe gegeben, dass das
ordentlich aussieht. Zumindest für
CIs. Na gut, okay.
Dann schaue ich
nochmal ganz kurz in meine Liste.
Noch zwei andere Themen, die hier in unseren Show Notes
drin vorkommen, unter der
Überschrift Warum nicht? Jetzt haben wir C++
und ganz kurz Heskel schon
erwähnt.
Wir haben ja noch Go mit drin.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass Go wahrscheinlich für
Linux-Könel auch nicht sonderlich interessant ist, weil es eine
menschliche Sprache ist und nicht so low-levelig läuft.
Go ist für nichts
interessant.
Wer hatte das neulich
irgendwo auf Twitter gepostet?
Who called it Go and not Erlang?
Das wäre sehr
passend. Aber ich will
jetzt auch gar nicht über Go ranten. Ich wollte es bloß mal, weil es
in unserer Liste drin steht.
Sig ist auch eine neue
Low-Level-Sprache, die an manchen
Stellen sich Mühe gibt, noch
low-leveliger zu sein als
Rust.
Warum Rust und nicht
SIG im Linux-Körnel?
Also ich habe
mir auch SIG mal angeguckt und
mein erstes Projekt war auch ein
Linux-Körnel-Modul zu schreiben.
Klar,
ein Rust-Körnel-Modul
in SIG.
Ein Linux-Körnel-Modul.
Das kriege ich heute
nicht mehr raus. Das wird jetzt immer der Rust-Körnel bleiben.
Ja,
Es ist auf jeden Fall, ich würde sagen, teilweise noch load-levellicher als Rust, weil zum Beispiel dieses, wie Allokia Speicher, das ist sehr explizit in SICK und die haben auch ein interessantes Fehlermodell, also wie die so, das nennt sich da Arrow Traces, also wie die so eine Art Stack Traces zusammenbauen können, wo man nachher findet, okay, der Fehler ist jetzt da und da entstanden und aus dem und dem Grund, das ist ziemlich cool und auch dieses Comp Time,
also Keyword, also dass man in SICK
zur Compile-Zeit eigentlich ziemlich viel, also ziemlich mächtige
Du kannst fast die gesamte Sprache zur Compile-Zeit bereits ausführen.
Genau, genau, genau.
Du hast keine Makros, sondern du hast einfach SICK.
Genau, das wird das eigentlich schon ziemlich,
ich glaube, das ist einfach so ein Timing-Problem, also RAST ist jetzt eigentlich schon viel weiter,
was die Adaption angeht, das ganze Tooling, was drumherum ist.
Also ich würde sagen, wenn SICK vielleicht eher gekommen wäre,
hätte es wahrscheinlich eine größere,
hätte es vielleicht eher noch eine Chance gehabt,
in den König reinzukommen.
Aber ich denke, RUST ist jetzt eigentlich schon von weiter.
Aber SICK, würde ich sagen, ist dann der Hauptgrund eher,
dass es nicht die gleichen Safety-Garantien wie RUST bietet, oder?
Also es kann ja an den selben Stellen um die Ohren fliegen
wie C oder C++ am meisten Stellen, oder?
Genau, aber es würde sich,
es hätte halt wieder andere Vorteile,
dass es sich besser in C integriert.
Also der C-Compiler ist ja auch gleichzeitig ein C-Compiler,
was dann den Vorteil hat,
dass man Makros teilweise sogar direkt importieren kann.
Also du kannst einfach sagen,
okay, ich inklude jetzt mal folgende Dateien oder so
und dann werden die dann halt direkt automatisch exportiert.
Das ist halt Teil der Sprache oder Teil der Default-Implementierung.
Gab es nicht sogar in irgendeinem Blogpost,
wie man C verwendet, um Rust mit C cross-zu-compilen,
indem man SIG als C-Compiler verwendet,
der ein bisschen Cross-Compiling-freundlicher ist als,
ich weiß nicht, ich muss es mal raussuchen.
Genau, genau.
Und zwar SIG, was das quasi macht,
oder warum das so gut in Cross-Compiling ist,
hängt damit zusammen,
dass es für jede Plattform,
für die es Cross-Compilen kann,
auch die C-Header mitliefert.
Also wenn ich jetzt für Windows kompiliere,
unter Linux ist das normalerweise sehr anstrengend,
weil ich erst mal mir irgendwie
die ganzen Header-Files zusammensuchen muss
der Zick-Compiler bundelt die halt alle
mit in dem Projekt mit. Das heißt, ich kann
halt, so wie ich das auch bei Go
unter anderem machen kann, dass ich einfach sagen kann,
okay, ich kompilier jetzt mal für alle möglichen Plattformen.
Ich kann nicht mehr quasi den Linker sparen,
das bringt der Compiler alles mit.
Genau, das ist halt so
ein komplettes Paket,
was dann alles miteinander funktioniert schon.
Wobei ich dann bei Rast muss ich ja dann erstmal
anfangen, mir die richtigen Zick-Compiler
noch dazu zu holen, oder
die Lipses, dass die richtig da liegen,
dass ich da für das Target bauen kann.
nachgefahren.
Zu diesen Makros ist natürlich, bei uns haben wir
damit im Rastverliebungs auch ein paar Probleme.
Zum Beispiel sind relativ viele Funktionen
im Linux-Könner auch mit Inline direkt
annotiert. Die werden dann nicht als
Symbol exportiert, sprich die kann man von Rast nicht
aufrufen. Teilweise machen wir
dann, dass wir die nochmal exportieren, dass wir eine
Nicht-Inline-Funktion machen, die diese Inline-Funktion
aufruft, um das zu
realisieren. Das ist natürlich auch irgendwo
nicht so schön, weil das dann auch wieder einen neuen Stack-Frame braucht
und das muss man irgendwann
mal auch angehen, aber aktuell haben wir da
doch keine sinnvolle Idee für und es funktioniert
auch so, es ist halt eventuell nicht ganz so schnell.
Cool.
Dankeschön.
Das war
kein guter Übergang.
Eine Sprache,
ich sage das in Anführungsstrichen,
die noch in unserer Liste auftaucht, ist
WebAssembly.
Inwiefern ist denn...
Hendrik will jetzt Körnel-Module in Timescript
basteln.
vielleicht in AssemblyScript
aber nee, warum ist denn
es gibt auch
oder anders
Click
ein Projekt, was ich auch gesehen habe, was interessant ist
für Kernelentwicklung
ist ein Projekt, ich habe leider
den Namen nicht parat
aber wir können den Link gerne nochmal in die Shownotes tun
das einen minimalen Kernel
gebaut hat
der dann alle
der ein Microkernel war und alle
darin laufenden Anwendungen oder vielleicht sogar Treiber
waren einfach WebAssembly-Module, die im Kernel
aufgerufen wurden, was den schönen Vorteil hatte,
dass man irgendwie eine Plattform hat und die Möglichkeiten
von diesen Binaries recht gut einschränkbar waren.
Inwiefern ist denn WebAssembly-Projekt, was spannend werden könnte
für Rust im Mikrokörnel eventuell?
das was? Also es gibt ja schon diverse
WebAssembly Runtimes in Rust, die
auch mitunter sehr, sehr, sehr im E-Mail sind.
Da gibt's
einen lustigen Talk dazu, den kann man sich
mal angucken. Und zwar
ist es der Death of JavaScript.
Der hat im Prinzip WebAssembly vorhergesagt.
Und es gibt auch noch ein
Paper von Microsoft,
das hieß SingularityOS.
Das war ein Betriebssystem,
wo man...
Ja, war das.NET oder so, Bytecode ausführen können oder so? Also in jedem Fall hatte man eine Art gemanagte Runtime in dem Kernel und das hat den Vorteil, dass man, also aktuell, wenn man, hat man ja eine Sepertierung zwischen Kernel und User Space, das heißt, wenn ich von den User Space in den Kernel rein will, dann muss ich quasi einen Kontext-Switch machen.
Dann springe ich von Ring 3 in Ring 0
und das ist ein Hardware-Future, der ist x86-Architektur.
Und das ist ja schon relativ,
das hat schon einen gewissen Overhead.
Da muss ich Sachen invalidieren, Caches invalidieren
und das ist teuer.
Und die Hypothese von,
wenn ich jetzt alles im gleichen Ring laufen lasse,
und zwar zum Beispiel eine Web-Essently-Runtime
oder bei Simularity irgendwann ein anderer Runtime verwende,
ist, dass ich zwar die Overhead von dieser Runtime habe,
die dann in Software ist, aber
dieser Overhead kleiner ist
als diese Context-Switche, die wir aktuell haben.
Ja, das kann man
sich in dem Dev of JavaScript Talk vielleicht nochmal angucken,
da wird das dann nur aufgeschlüsselt und
gut erklärt.
Und deswegen gibt es auch
bereits so
Kernel-Module, die WebAssembly
in den Linux-Kernel bringen.
Das sind aber halt auch so
GitHub-Projekte oder so. Ich weiß nicht,
das wird wahrscheinlich nie irgendwie...
So your copy-Projekt-Level quasi.
Genau. Ich hab das mal
irgendwie in dem Hackerspace an dem Arm
zusammengehackt oder so.
Ja.
Aber ist das was, wo
ihr meint, das hat Merit?
Das ist eigentlich eine Idee, das könnte man
für Treiber verwenden oder für
Filesysteme verwenden
oder ist das spannend oder ist das Gratsch?
Es gibt ja schon so was
wie EBNF.
EBF.
Was eine Skriptsprache ist,
faktisch im Kernel.
Könnte man das mit WebAssembly machen?
Ja, also schon genau deswegen,
weil es EPPF schon gibt.
Also das ist so eine Art,
EPPF ist so eine Art Bytecode-Interpreter
im Kernel.
Und das kann man benutzen,
um zum Beispiel
das gesamte System zu tracen,
weil du kannst dann zum Beispiel sagen,
okay, wenn ich jetzt in diese Funktion reinspringe,
dann füge noch diesen kleinen Stück
Bytecode mit aus und dann kann ich mal irgendwie Sachen
zählen oder so.
Ja, aber weil es dieses
EPPF schon gibt, deswegen denke ich, wird es wahrscheinlich
auch unwahrscheinlicher, dass WebAssembly reinkommt,
weil viele Sachen
werden immer mehr mit diesem EPPF gemacht.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel mittlerweile,
wenn du Dateien öffnest
oder I.O. machst, kannst du
teilweise schon so kleine EPPF-Programme
mit dranhängen, die dann
bestimmte Funktionalitäten
lagern, wo dann gar nichts mehr, wo dann
der Linken
in ein Süßesbächer kommen muss und zum Beispiel
so eine Kette von I.O.
Operationen schon hintereinander ausführen kann.
Also wahrscheinlich wird es eher EPPF werden
als WebAssembly. Aber war
EPPF nicht auch ein riesen Sicherheitsproblem?
Gab es da nicht irgendwie auch schon Kongress
Vorträge dazu, dass EPPF eigentlich
eine doofe Idee ist?
Ja, also wenn
EPPF ein Sicherheitsproblem ist, dann weiß ich nie,
was WebAssembly ist.
EPPF hat nämlich schon bestimmte Sicherheitsgarantien
die...
War nicht das Problem, dass es mindestens zwei
unterschiedliche EPPF-Implementierungen
im Kernel bereits gibt? Wenn nicht sogar drei?
Gut, wie viele es da gibt,
weiß ich nicht. Wahrscheinlich gibt es
BPF, also was diese ursprüngliche
okay, ich mache jetzt nur Firewalls
Filter ist. Und dann gibt es EPPF,
was dann die
erweiterte Variante, die generische Variante ist.
Ob es jetzt noch mehr Implementierungen gibt, da bin ich jetzt
gerade leider nie im Bild.
Aber es gibt halt ein Clang-Backend oder ein LVM-Backend-EPF,
den kann man eigentlich alle möglichen Sprachen,
die man mit LVM bauen kann.
Die kann man dann nach EPPF runterkompilieren.
Und EPPF hat ja diese Eigenschaft,
dass es terminiert, das Programm.
Also du kannst in EPPF, kannst du keine Schleifen bauen,
die unendlich lange laufen.
Du hast halt immer eine begrenzte Ranslaufzeit
und du kannst das eigentlich ziemlich gut abschätzen,
wie langsam das Programm maximal läuft.
Und das ist halt ein sehr wichtiges Property,
weil dann kann man halt, also der Code, den man damit schreibt,
der kann halt nichts kaputt machen in dem Sinne.
Ist das was, was man sieht, wenn man nach eBPF kompiliert,
wenn ich jetzt ein C-Programm schreibe,
was einfach eine Endlos-Loop implementiert und das nach eBPF kompiliere?
Kompiliert das dann einfach nicht? Oder wie funktioniert das?
Es kompiliert schon, aber sobald du das versuchst,
dann in den Kernel zu laden,
beschwert sich der Körner mit einer sehr unleserlichen
Fehlermeldung, das ist der Code
jetzt gerade nicht. Das führe ich nicht aus.
Das wäre einfach ein Tipp.
Genau, also wenn man EPP-FM benutzen
will, will man nie dieses
normale Clang, dieses normale Clang-Target
nehmen, sondern man benutzt eine Library,
die heißt BCC.
Die ist von
diesem Tracing-Guru
Pratt & Crack?
Nee, Pratt & Crack.
Wir finden es raus, dann fügen wir es in die Show Notes.
genau
und die
gibt ihnen dann fünftige Fehlermeldungen raus
also die versuchen dann teilweise so die Fehlermeldung
die dieser
Körnel da rausspuckt
entgegenzunehmen und dann zu interpretieren
und was zu übersetzen, was ein Mensch versteht
was aber eigentlich
also eigentlich ist das
ganz cool dann wiederum, weil diesen Code
den man da schreibt, das ist so eine Art
Subset von C
und ich würde sagen, das ist das sichere C
weil das verhindert halt so Out-of-Boundaries,
das verhindert endlos schleifen, also Code,
der dann irgendwann mit BCC kompiliert,
der ist dann halt, der funktioniert
vielleicht noch nie, aber der
zumindest hat ja keine Runtime-Probleme.
Es gibt auch
mittlerweile libbpf,
das ist, meine ich, aus dem Kernel
direkt, also das müsste im
Kernelsource-Tools oder so liegen,
damit kann man das Ganze auch laden
und natürlich mit dem LLVM-Target gibt's
auch ein Rastprojekt, das will nur nicht so
wirklich kompilieren, aber es ist existent.
Ah, ausgezeichnet. Nochmal als Kontext,
was genau möchte man mit
solchen Miniskripten
oder mit sowas
dann im Normalfall ausführen?
Was ist so der
normale Use Case, außer
Firewall-Regeln?
TCP-Dump.
Zum Beispiel TCP-Dump nutzt so eine
eBPF-Regel, um halt, wenn
man da einen Filter ranmacht, ich will jetzt nur Traffic von
480 sehen, dann lädt der einfach direkt diesen
diesen Filter, in dem das Socketwasser
sich aufmacht und hat damit viel weniger Wasser
verarbeiten muss.
Ah ja, fallen euch noch Beispiele ein, warum ich das
und Mick ist weg.
Ist er noch da?
Ja, ich bin auch da.
Ich müsste bloß mal kurz meinen Schützchen neu starten.
Andere Projekte, die man
mit
BPEF macht, ist halt, also
hauptsächlich ist es halt so Tracing-Geschichten,
also man kann so Performance-
Sachen messen, also so Counter
sich anlegen und Dinge messen,
die vorher wirklich nicht möglich waren.
Also zum, es gibt da
diese Visualisierungsmethode,
die
da verwendet wird, die heißt
Flamecrafts.
Da hat man quasi so eine Gesamtsicht
auf die Systemperformance. Man sieht dann quasi im gesamten
System, was jedes Prozess macht
oder wo er die meiste Zeit
verbringt. Und sowas lässt sich
dann zum Beispiel mit... Stopp. Mute dich mal bitte
in JetZ.
Okay.
So was kann man dann gut mit
eBPF machen.
Das heißt, aber ich dachte, der Flame Graph
wird direkt irgendwie vom Scheduler oder sowas
erzeugt oder was macht
das eBPF dann beim Flame Graph
genau?
Ja, das
liefert quasi den Code, der
das Tracing im Kernel übernimmt.
Also du kannst, wenn du auf die BCC
Webseite gehst, auf der GitHub-Seite,
da hast du so eine kleine Grafik, du hast dann
verschiedene Subsysteme und je nach Subsystem gibt es
dann irgendwie so ein kleines Tool, was genau
für dieses Subsystem oder es gibt mehrere, die
dann dafür super sind, um irgendwie
Performance-Probleme zu finden, zum Beispiel
gibt es ein Tool, das heißt SysCount,
das zählt dir einfach, welche
System-Calls gerade abgerufen werden auf dem System,
wie viel, wie lange die brauchen oder du kannst zum Beispiel
sagen, okay, gib mir mal alle System-Calls,
die länger als x Millisekunden
brauchen, dann siehst du quasi, was jetzt langsam
ist und kannst
ziemlich gut
rausfinden, was dein Problem ist.
Ah, krass. Gut, das war jetzt ein kleiner
Tangent zum Thema
eBPF
und warum man
WebAssembly nicht unbedingt im Linux-Körner
braucht.
Cool. Das heißt,
ich könnte quasi jetzt schon
externen Rust-Code, was weiß ich,
nehmen mal ein konstruiertes Beispiel,
ich habe was, was ich in meinem
Treiber mitlaufen lassen muss, was
JSON-Dateien passt.
Da möchte ich jetzt nicht ein ganzes Serre irgendwie in meinen Rust mit reinschmeißen,
sondern das könnte man jetzt so als WebAssembly oder als Rust mit,
als EBPF mit reinbauen, dann könnte man das irgendwie zur Runtime laden.
Das ist dann schon wieder ein bisschen sehr konsolidiert, was ich gerade brauche, oder?
Ich weiß gerade auch nicht, ob es geht, weil EBPF ist vor allen Dingen,
soweit ich das bis jetzt verstanden habe, was wie XDP, also dieses Express Data Path,
um dann halt Pakete und so zu machen, also bestehenden Codes sich zu hooken.
Du kannst natürlich in deinem Kernel, wo du, soweit ich weiß,
nur ranlegen dafür.
Weiß aber nicht genau, wie das dann funktioniert.
Also ich hatte jetzt überlegt, ob es ein Use Case wäre,
so größere Anwendungen im Kernelspace laufen zu lassen,
damit ich mir halt genau diese Context-Switches sparen kann
und diese gleichen Performance-Vorteile habe,
wie bei diesem Kernel-Projekt, was alles in WebAssembly ausführt.
Kann man das jetzt schon mit eBPF und man macht das einfach nicht?
Oder ist das Quatsch, was ich gerade erzähle?
Meines Wissens würde es nicht gehen, aber ich habe
BPF bis jetzt kaum verwendet.
Alles klar.
Ja, war auch bloß so eine kurze Überlegung.
Wenn wir das jetzt alles
abgehakt haben, wie schaut denn die Reise für die Zukunft
aus? Wo sollst du generell hingehen? Was wären denn so
die nächsten Schritte und was ist
denn so die Vision?
Also die nahe Zukunft ist auf jeden Fall
wirklich nur dieser Treiber, Binder
E1000S, wenn ich dann da irgendwann
zukomme, der Hardware
Random Number Generator auf
Pi, all diese Geschichten
und wenn das dann
implementiert ist und das überläuft und
GCCR ist, soweit fertig ist, dass man damit
den Rastteil vom Linux-Körnel bauen kann,
dann ist auch die Idee, ob das
eventuell irgendwann mal in die Subsysteme reinkommt,
sprich nicht Treiber-Code
und dass dann jeder Linux-Körnel mit Rast
gebaut werden muss. Das ist aber
wirklich sehr, sehr ferne Zukunftsmusik.
Erstmal wirklich nur Treiber, Treiber, Treiber
oder überhaupt schauen,
welche Treiber werden angenommen, weil es kann natürlich
sein, dass das Subsystem-Netzwerk
meinen E1000, beziehungsweise generell
überhaupt kein Rast akzeptiert, auch nicht für E1000,
nicht den Dummy-Treiber, gar nichts.
Das muss man bei den
Subsystem-Maintainern schauen, beziehungsweise
Treiber-Subsystem-Maintainern.
Das hängt auch an den einzelnen Menschen fest, dann
die Entscheidung. Also das ist jetzt,
oder wäre es eine technische Entscheidung, dass die halt
das aus Gründen nicht annehmen, oder meinst du, das ist dann
wirklich eine emotionalere Sache
wie Linus mit Zimus?
Die müssen sich schon irgendwo ein bisschen
natürlich rechtfertigen und
da kann natürlich dann auch Linus irgendwann mal
sagen, so, nehmt das doch jetzt mal bitte an
und das ist guter Code,
aber prinzipiell liegt es
natürlich auch doch irgendwo an den Maintainern, die dann
dieses Treibend hin müssen.
Okay, da gibt es den, logisch.
Aber der Rattenschwanz ist, dass man
ja quasi zum Bildsystem vom
Linux-Körner in einen kompletten Ancompiler hinzufügt.
So, und
was habt ihr so für ein Gefühl?
Mik,
hört man dich eigentlich wieder?
Sehr schön.
Was habt ihr für so ein Gefühl, zum Beispiel
von Linus?
Wie ist der der ganzen Sache
gegenüber so eingestellt? Ich weiß, diese eine Rant
über das Panicking
oder die Allocation, die war irgendwie
eine Nachricht, aber ist der
relativ offen für das Projekt?
Oder ist das eher was, wo ihr ein bisschen gegen...
Mach du weg.
Es gab da auf der Plunder-Konferenz, glaube ich,
das ist so die Linus-Entwickler-Konferenz,
da gab es irgendwie auch
so einen Ruhm für Rust und das war, glaube ich,
der am meisten besuchteste Talk. Also da ist schon
ein sehr großes Interesse von verschiedenen Leuten,
dass sowas reinkommt, deswegen bin ich da
positiv gegenüber.
Es gibt sogar die Idee, dass ich meine nächsten
oder übernächsten Monat mal eine komplette Konferenz
komme zu Rast im Linux-Körner, eine komplett eigene,
die dann dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich
virtuell ist und dann nächstes Jahr, wenn alles gut geht,
in Spanien.
Ich soll vielleicht einen Talk halten.
Da habe ich glaube ich mal auch mal von.
sehr cool
sehr cool, dann haben wir doch alle was
wo wir ein Auge drauf werfen können
wir werden noch hoffentlich genügend
von den Sachen die wir hier angesprochen haben
in den Shownotes verlinken können
an dieser Stelle
vielen lieben Dank
für diese sehr titeljätten Ausführung
das war unglaublich faszinierend
für diese titeljätten Ausführung
ich würde unseren beiden Gästen jetzt noch
die Möglichkeit geben, noch irgendein anderes Projekt
zu picken oder zu placken
oder als
Bonus mit in unsere Show Notes reinzuschmeißen,
was ihr cool findet.
Fängt vielleicht an.
Und zwar, was ich jetzt,
vielleicht nicht unbedingt
so gut zu empfinden, aber für
viele andere Git-Repositoris.
Hä?
Er hat Linus-König.
Oh ja. Ich habe jetzt
meinen Rechner gebotet und wahrscheinlich auch meinen Brain
damit und deswegen ist das jetzt wieder alles
gesettet.
Also es gibt ein cooles
Git-Kommando,
der heißt LazyTerm.
Also Kommando-Zahlen-Clients gab es
vorher, es gibt auch einige Git-Clients.
Aber LazyTerm hat halt
echt advanced
Rebase-Features, also so, dass ich
denken kann, okay, ich nehme jetzt irgendwie, ich vertausche
jetzt Commits und das ist dann halt irgendwie
nicht mehr, ich muss jetzt irgendwie 10 Git-Kommandos eingeben,
sondern das ist dann halt irgendwie
zwei Tastenkombinationen.
Also es fühlt sich an wie so ein richtiger
für die Gist-Historie, wo du dann sagen kannst,
okay, ich habe jetzt irgendwie einen Patch
und Teile von dem Patch ziehe ich jetzt
in den anderen Commit rein und dann werden die aus dem
ersten Commit entfernt, in den neuen Commit reingemacht.
Also wenn du irgendwie so Leute hast, die sagen können,
okay, strukturieren wir deinen Git-Commit anders,
ja, kannst du
halt damit echt viel mehr machen,
als du mit so einem normalen, mit der normalen Git-Huia
machen kannst. Obdanns, weil es viel umständlicher
funktioniert, weil du da irgendwie
stashen musst und die ganzen Low-Level-Features
kennen musst und dort gibt es halt
bei LazyGit auf der Webseite
gibt es halt ein Video von dem Hauptentwickler
und der zeigt dann so die ganzen
Sachen, die LazyGit beherrscht
und das ist seitdem so mein
guter Git-Client geworden.
Das gehört mich ein bisschen an die
Mac-App Git ab, die
auch den Ansatz verfolgt, dass man
doch scheiß auf das, was Git kann.
Wir bauen einfach direkt im Git-Object-Store rum
und machen da magische Dinge und deswegen gibt es
ja auch recht witzige Futures zur Hand,
die Git so sonst dir
nicht offenbart, aus guten Gründen, aber
wenn man mal was anderes machen muss, genau wie das, was du gerade geschrieben hast,
dann ist GitHub die schöne UI dafür.
Abgefahren. Lazy Git, nicht schlecht.
Ja, doch, durchaus. Ich habe, muss ich sagen,
ich bin ja auch in Nix unterwegs und da mal Builds zu
debuggen und so, da muss man schon sagen, die Software Center
ist da sehr gut für.
Es ist witzig, weil das ist ein Projekt, was ich quasi
meines PhDs entwickelt habe.
Das hat mit Nix erst mal wenig zu tun.
Das ist eigentlich so ein generisches
Tool, mit dem man sich an
verschiedene Container, also
Docker, Kubernetes
Sachen oder halt die Nix
Sendbox dranhängen kann.
CNTR.
Ach, das Projekt heißt
Oh, das ist ein guter Hinweis.
Da kann dann noch
Retro-Perspektiv kann ich da noch neue
Interpretationen
einbauen.
Ah, ich habe es gerade gefunden, es lebt wirklich
beim Mic auf dem Gitter.
Ja,
es gibt
eben dann in dem Container
die Möglichkeit,
Programme auszuführen, die eigentlich
gar nicht in dem Container vorher drin waren.
Also man kann quasi von seinem
Host kann man sich an so einen Container dranhängen
und ist dann quasi wieder in dem Container
drin, also man sieht dann alle die Prozesse,
die in dem Container drin sind, aber man hat sein
Dateisystem, was man vom Host hat,
das wird dann durchgeschleift
und ja,
denselben Ansatz, den baue ich jetzt
quasi noch für VMs, wo es
aber um einiges
komplizierter ist,
weil man da viel mehr Sachen machen muss.
Ich bin sehr gespannt auf das Paper.
Ich würde gerade sagen, wenn du sowas bastelst,
dann schreibst du auch immer gleich ein Paper drüber, oder?
Ja, ja, genau.
Also das, ich bin jetzt
kurz davor,
mit der Implementierung bin ich jetzt fast fertig
und dann wird mein Paper drüber geschrieben
und das wird dann noch mein PhD sein,
also komplett sein.
Nicht schlecht,
nicht schlecht. Cool.
Center, schmeißt uns mal die Links
über den Zaun.
Über den Haufen.
Ja, cool, vielen Dank.
Ich glaube, wir haben damit jetzt auch den Zeitrahmen
bei weitem ausgeschöpft.
Es war super spannend,
mit euch mal drüber geredet zu haben, über
Rust und Linux-Körnel oder Linux und Rust-Körnel
oder wie auch immer,
das demnächst
ausgesprochen wird.
Vielen Dank, Jörg. Vielen Dank, Finn.
Cool.
Damit würde ich das letzte Wort
gerne dem Finn überlassen
und mich
bei unseren Zuhörern
von
von Akronomisierbar Folge 51
verabschieden.
Und Finn, bitte.
Der nächste Podcast
in eurem Podcast-Star
kommt dann auch in 3, 2, 1.